hey everyone welcome back to simply
loans youtube channel in this session we
will be talking about the resolutions
for 2022. now you might be wondering
what resolutions am i going to talk
about the resolutions which you have
decided to learn master and get ahead so
in this session we will be talking about
java aspirants
so what better way to start a new year
with learning the most powerful and
leading programming language in the
current id industry which is java now
according to the stats java is the most
prominent programming language ruling
the iit industry since years and it is
also expected to rule the industry in
the coming years ahead as well now it is
also proven that major id companies are
in a constant hunt for java developers
including the fan companies which are
the facebook or meta amazon apple
netflix google and many more and also
the salary for java developers is really
high the average basic salary of a java
developer in the entry level is anywhere
between 5 lakh rupees per annum to 1
million rupees per annum and similarly
for a java developer in american nations
the salary is between anywhere around
100 us dollars to 180 us dollars per
annum now with the brief introduction
about the importance of learning java in
the new year and making it a resolution
to master java now we will type into the
agenda for today's java crash course
session so we will start off with a
brief introduction to java programming
language then we will try to install
java programming language in our local
system followed by that we will go
through some of the important java
fundamentals where we will learn about
java data types variables loops etc once
we are done with the fundamentals we
will dive into the objects and classes
and object oriented paradigms in java
then we will start off with abstract
classes in java next we have
encapsulation in java inheritance in
java and polymorphism in java these four
are the important object-oriented
paradigms in java next we will start off
with java collections framework once we
are done with java collections framework
we will enter the exception handling in
java where we will learn about errors
and exceptions in java and try to handle
the unforeseen exceptions in java in
real time followed by that we will learn
about jdbc also known as java database
connection followed by that we will
enter the advanced java concepts where
we will learn about java servlets java
application programming interface
enterprise edition of java and code
testing fundamentals in the junit
tutorial followed by that we will go
through some of the most frequently
asked java interface questions and
finally we will wind up the session by
discussing some of the top 10 most
prominent and popular java project ideas
for your portfolio i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now without
further ado let's get started with the
crash course based on java for 2022. now
over to our experts
hi guys welcome to this video that will
tell you everything you need to know
about the class-based object-oriented
programming language java
java is an object-oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a high
level language that is easy to read and
understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices it is used not only
in computers and mobiles but even in
electronic devices like televisions
washing machines air conditioners and so
on online forms banking and shopping are
possible because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991.
he had a single moto while creating the
language it was right once run anywhere
this meant that the code would have to
be written only once but it could be
used anywhere they named this language
oak because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named to
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object oriented programming
language based on c and c plus however
it is improved and simplified to solve
the errors in programming java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the java
interpreter the whole java code is run
on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided into different sections in a
supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine it is a very secure
language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install java on
your windows 10 operating system after
we're done with this installation we'll
also show you how you can run a very
simple program so now let's get started
so now let's download java let's go to
google and search for java download
we'll go to the link we see here
oracle.com so now here we have the web
page
here we can see java se13 so this is
version 13 but this isn't the one we are
going to download we're going to
download the eighth version version 8
which is here now we're doing this
because 8 is one of the more commonly
used versions of java
so let's click this
and here we'll go down we need to accept
the license agreement before we can
download it
now we have two versions here x86 and
x64 now you can download it depending on
what version your operating system is
now if you do have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this
so we've actually already logged in so
we just need to run the installer file
now let's go to downloads
and run the file
so here we have the installer we go to
the next step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed to
we'll go to next
now if you want to change where you want
to install java we can press the change
option i'm just going to keep it here
we'll press next and let's commence with
installation
and there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or api documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close
now to see if java is installed in your
system we can go to command prompt
and type the term java c
which refers to the java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates that
java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
java c is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now
and now we're going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a dot java
extension this environment variable
tells the computer that the java program
needs to be called to run this
particular file
so to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control panel
here go into system and security
go to system and select advanced system
settings and then this shows up now
before we go into environment variables
we'll need to go to where the java file
was installed so let's go to this pc
c drive
program files
and here let's go to java
so let's go to jdk which is the java
development kit let's go to bin here
and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here
and then press on
new paste this
and okay now we'll go back
and go to jre to the path of jre which
is java runtime environment we click on
this
pin again
and copy this path
select this one
new
and paste that
and there we go the environment
variables are now set
now let's talk about running that simple
program i told you about now this is
possible with the help of an ide an ide
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code java we
will be using eclipse and intellij as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other ides
that are available in the market so now
let's work with eclipse let's go to
google and search for eclipse
we'll go to this link
press download and then this shows up
let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so i'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
downloads
and select eclipse with this you can see
that there are multiple options for you
to choose from so we're going to select
eclipse ide for java developers now you
have other options like for cnc plus
plus javascript php and so on let's go
to the first one and here you have the
details you can change them if you want
but i'm just going to go ahead with
installation now
you press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept
and then here as well we'll remember
accepted certificates select this one
and accept selected
and there you go the installation is now
complete
let's click on launch now
so here we are setting up a directory as
a workspace i'm not changing it here so
i'm just going to go with launch
here we have the eclipse workspace now
let's close this first and here we have
the package explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
show view
and select on package explorer
so now let's go to file
new and java project we need to set up a
project name i'm going to call it my
project
one
go to next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your
program is going to be stored then let's
finish and now we'll click on my project
1
go to source
i click new
and create a class
explain
i'll name the class my class
and create it
and here we have it so now let's write a
simple program to multiply two numbers
so now let's write the main function
open
bracket
now we're going to initialize the first
number
now the second one
and finally the output
and finally the variable that will store
the output
now we'll just give them a simple print
statement
now let's run the code by clicking this
option here
using my cluster java and there we have
it here the product is shown to be 100
indicating that the program is running
successfully
now we're done with eclipse now let's
move on to the other ide i was talking
about which is intellij so for that
again we'll have to go back to google so
that we can download it search for
intellij download go to this link here
so here you can see that we have two
options the ultimate edition and the
community version
now here the ultimate version has way
more options as you can see here but
it's a paid version and only has a free
trial
now the community version is free so
that's what we're going to take so we'll
click on download here so i've already
downloaded the software so i don't need
to do it again
so i'm going to go to downloads
and
so here we go let's just click on next
select the location where you want to
install it press next now we will add a
64-bit launcher shortcut on the desktop
and create association so basically this
means that these are the different file
extensions that this will support so dot
java dot groovy and now let's go to the
next step we'll install now and we'll
wait and there we go the installation is
now complete let's not import any
settings
we'll accept the privacy policy we'll
set defaults
now let's create a new project so here
make sure your project sdk is set to the
version of java you've installed make
sure this isn't blank we'll go to next
here you need to select this option
which is the create project from
template and we are now going to create
a command line application
press next
name the project which i'm going to call
my approach
to
you can change the location if you want
i'm just going to keep it the way it is
and then click on finish
so now we're going to create a simple
program through which based on the
user's input we can determine whether a
number is even or odd
so first we're going to import the
package scanner through which we can
take the user's input
next let's go inside here let's create
available reader
now let's ask for the user's input
enter a number
we're taking in the value now
in the variable num
dot reader.net int
so this is with which we'll be taking in
the value from the user
so we're going to set up a condition to
determine whether the number is even or
not
so if the number
and when divided by 2 provides the
remainder 0 it indicates that it's an
even number
we'll show them then
now for the else case
the number is not even
or in this case odd
there we go
we're done so let's run this program
so let's enter 12
the number is even
and there we go we have a successful
output this indicates that the program
is running successfully let's begin with
the fundamentals so the first one in the
fundamentals is the data types so every
programming language has a data type so
what exactly is a data type so whatever
the input you provide in your program is
a data type for example if you provide
numbers so in that particular numbers we
have a different variety of numbers if
you are given just 1 2 3 so on without a
decimal number then that particular type
of input which is a number will be
considered as integer type if you
provide the same number with a decimal
point then that will be considered as
float and if you have the range greater
than float it will be considered as
double and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language so the most frequently used
data types in java programming languages
are as follows at first we have the byte
followed by that we have short end long
next float then double boolean and
finally care apart from this we also
have few other data types but these are
the most frequently used ones for all
the basic programmings so this is made
for beginners basically so you can take
a quick screenshot of this particular
slide so that you can have a quick
overview or reference to all the data
types in java programming language so i
hope you have taken a screenshot of this
now let's begin with the next concept so
in the next concept we have the keywords
and variables so all the programming
languages have variables and keywords so
variables are used to store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values that is 5 and 10. so in
order to do so you might want to create
a variable which stores them for example
you wanted to store the value of 10 in a
certain variable a and the 5 in a
certain variable b so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is a is equals
to a plus b then the value of a which
was previously 10 will be updated to 15
so here you can see the value is varying
and also it is storing the result so
this is why the variables are used in a
program in order to store a value and
this particular term variable is used
because the value can change at any
instance of time once after a certain
arithmetic or a logical operation is
performed on that particular variable so
similarly we have keywords unlike
variables keywords have a special
meaning no matter whatever you try you
cannot change the meaning of that
keyword for example consider main so you
cannot use the term main for normal
things because the part or the term main
is dedicated for a different purpose so
whenever you try to execute your java
program the control flow will start
executing the program right when it
reads the term main
so it has a special meaning similarly
you have other keywords such as end so
that is dedicated for integer type of
values and float for float type of
values that is a decimal values and byte
for byte care for character type data
string for string so every keyword or
every term with special meaning which is
predefined and cannot be changed is
called as a keyword now let's see the
most frequently used keywords in java
programming language so similar to the
previous one we have a table here so in
this particular table we have the most
frequently used keywords in java so you
can see we have boolean final byte
native and we have void switch so switch
is a
conditional statement so we have if it
is also a conditional statement we will
go through this conditional statements
as we proceed in our tutorial and you
can also see the protected so this term
which is protected public so this is
basically the access modifier even this
particular keyword have special meaning
this public this protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extends so
extension this term comes in inheritance
so inheritance is one of the crucial
concepts of object-oriented programming
can also see abstraction so this we will
be dealing in the next upcoming part
where we will understand the object
oriented programming concepts next we
have interface return and so on you can
also see some keywords like through so
throw will come in exception handling so
we will also learn about exception
handling in the upcoming part so these
are the most frequently used keywords in
java so now we will move ahead into our
next concept so the next concept is the
operators in java so to understand
operators let's go through a table so on
my screen you can see a table which has
some arithmetic operators which are most
commonly used that is the plus for
addition minus the subtraction similarly
we have star forward slash double plus
double minus so double plus and double
minus say they are increment and
decrement operators respectively as you
can see we have a plus plus here which
means the post increment so the first
value will be read after that the value
will be updated next we have the
pre-increment the value will be
incremented first then the updated value
will be stored so that's that's how the
increment and decrement operators work
so we have the modulus over here so to
understand the operators that we use in
java in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program so on my screen
you can see a program which is based on
operators so we are currently on the
eclipse ide don't worry about the ids
and java etc etc so i will drop a link
in the description box below which will
explain you in a very detailed way about
how to install java into your local
system and how to install eclipse ide in
your local system and also how to create
your first project how to create your
package how to create a new class how to
write your program and how to run that
how to see the output and a complete
overview of the eclipse ide how that
works so everything will be linked in
the description box below you don't have
to worry about that so right now to save
time i have created the text document
which has all the programs that we will
be executing today so i will also drop a
link for that particular file so that
you can have complete access to that
file so that you can run the programs in
your personal
pcs or laptops and also understand the
programs in a much better way so now
let's begin with the program so this
particular program is basically designed
for automatic operations so you can see
we have the operators that is the
addition subtraction multiplication
division modulus and exit so basically
we will be taking input from mu so the
input will be taken by the user that is
we are using scanner class here so
scanner class takes the input from user
and that particular input will be
compared here so we are using the switch
case here so if you provide the option
as one then addition operation will be
run similarly second force abstraction
third for multiplication fourth for
division fifth for modulus and sixth to
exit so this is how the
loop or the program works for automatic
operations now let's quickly run this
program and see the output so you can
see the program got successfully
executed and we have the console asking
for the first input let's provide some
random number
now let's provide the second number so
there you go we have our options over
here now let's choose
division operation for that we need to
provide the number four so there you go
we have the result over here which is 4.
now the loop has started once again now
it's in the starting stage again it's
asking for numbers now let's provide a
25 and
5.
now let's choose some operation that is
edition so for that you need to provide
one so we have the result again that is
30.
now
let's again choose some number 10
5 so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so i hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry i
have linked the
document in the description box below
you can take the access of that
particular document and you can check
the program and run in your local system
and also you can make some modifications
to it as you can see we don't have a
default case over here i've just placed
the case one two six and
i'm seeing the default because you can
see that the options are from one to six
what if the user provides the number as
seven right so the program might crash
over here so for that purpose you can
write in another case that would be the
default case so the default case will
check if the number is anything above or
out of the range of one to six then it
should be providing you with an output
saying a wrong input has been given or
check your input or something similar so
that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that so now let's quickly begin
with our next concept so in the next
concept we have the conditional
statements so what are the conditional
statements or the control statements so
basically these are some
yeah these are conditions so what
happens is just imagine that
you wanted to do something or if you
wanted to drive a vehicle or if you
wanted to drive a bike so the condition
you will apply on your mind is if i know
driving then i will do it if not i'll
not do it so that's what you do right so
basically you apply a condition on your
mind and you do it if it is capable of
doing or if you are capable of doing it
so in the same way the conditional
statements play a major role in computer
logic so before writing a code or before
you start your program you provide the
condition perform this particular
operation if the provided condition is
satisfied so similarly you have
these three conditional statements in
java which are if else and nested if so
we use these conditional statements in
java to implement our logic so we will
understand the conditional statements
particularly if if else and nested if in
a much more detailed way by practically
running some programs based on these
three types of conditional statements so
now you can see that we are back on the
eclipse right now so this particular
code segment is based on the if
condition i hope the program is visible
let's try to increase the font size so i
think it's better now so basically we
have an input so we have the integer
type of input that is num and we have
the number as minus hundred so it is a
negative number and after that we have
the if condition so this is where the
conditional statement is provided so the
condition is if the number is greater
than 0 if the provided number is greater
than 0 then the control should enter the
loop which is this particular segment
and execute the statements present
inside that particular loop so here we
have one single statement that is a
print statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition fails then
what happens is that instead of entering
this particular code segment this
particular code segment the control will
skip and execute the next statement that
is another printf statement which we
have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block
now since we have provided a negative
number the second option should go ahead
now let's try to run this and see the
output so there you go as expected the
program got executed and we have only
one statement that is if condition is
terminated control is outside the block
now let's write otherwise let's just
eliminate the negative number and now
check it again there you go now you can
see the program got executed and now we
have two print statements you can see
that the condition here was true so the
control entered into the statement or
the code block and this particular
statement got executed successfully once
the statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printer
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example
for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first if condition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to zero if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else else if this condition
fails then what you must do the control
should avoid entering this particular
segment and it should directly hit the
next segment where we have the else
block which has another statement which
says the number is negative so this is
how the program works so here we will be
doing a little modification over there
instead of taking an input which is
previously defined as it was in the
previous example where we had given
minus 100 previously we are going to do
it a little differently this time we'll
be taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java.util.scanner
so this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program was
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user now
let's try to provide a negative number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that since we had given a negative
number the control did not enter this
particular code segment at all it
directly avoided to enter this code
segment and entered into the else block
and executed the statements present in
that particular else block which was a
simple print statement that had the
statement which read as the number is
negative now let's try to execute the
same program again and see what would be
the output so there you go now it's
asking for the input again now this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since we provided the number as a
positive number this condition was true
and this particular statement got
executed
since one of the statements executed
there was no need for the else block to
be executed again so you can see this
particular code segment runs in this way
so once the condition is checked so if
the condition is true then the true
statement will be executed in case if
the conditions result is false then the
false statements will be executed so you
will be provided with two options so one
option for true validity and another
option for false validity so this is how
the if else block works i hope you
understood this now with this let's
continue with the next type of
conditional statement that is the lzf
ladder so on my screen you can see there
is a change of program we have stepped
into the next type of conditional
statement that is the lsf ladder so
basically everything will be seen we
will be provided with only one condition
so we will be checking the validity of
that particular condition so if the
provided condition is true then the
first one will be executed if it is not
then the second one will be executed if
the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed and the fourth and if
all the four fails then we will have one
last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
lc flatter works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and say the
output so basically we are going to
take an input from the user so we will
be entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else then one two three
four then we will be having an else
statement which says it's an invalid
input so the flow of this particular
elsif statement is similar to the switch
statement having said that we will also
discuss something about switch statement
as well basically we'll try to execute a
program based on
switch statement and we will also
understand the control flow of that
don't worry about it now let's quickly
execute this particular program first so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an input
let's select noodles that's how it works
we have the output nodals so the choice
is equal to is equals to one so the
first one was true so it executed the
first code segment and everything else
got suspended because this was not
necessary to be executed because the
condition was true over here and
according to that only this particular
statement was supposed to be executed so
that's how it works now let's switch
into the next conditional statement
which is the switch so you can see that
we have a program on my screen which is
based on switch case
so you can see that there is some
similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators so we
also have the default code segment over
here so this was what i was talking
about you can add a default code segment
in that particular program which is the
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there now
basically what happens in this
particular code segment is so we have
monday as the day one of a week tuesday
at the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on one two three four and so
on to seven and if you provide anything
else than one two seven you will be
provided with an message which says
invalid input so now let's try to
run this program and see the output so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now let's select
the weekend day so which would be
something between six and seven so six
is saturday and seven is sunday let's go
with seven so there you go sunday now
let's try to execute this program once
again and give a wrong input and see if
it works or not let's provide eight
there you go the program identified it
as a wrong input so it gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default code segment in switch case so
you can implement this in that operators
program and check out how it works can
be considered as a homework though not a
problem now this is how the switch case
works so with this let's move ahead into
the next concept in our java tutorial
for today so the next segment is about
the loops
so what are loops
so conditional statements are
some statements which get executed based
on a condition if the condition is true
if not then that particular condition
will not be executed loops are a little
different from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement and you wanted
to execute that one single statement for
a particular number of times so in that
condition instead of writing the same
code segment for several number of times
you can just use a loop for example
consider that you wanted to print
numbers from 1 to 10. so the brute force
method or the simple or the first method
that fires to your mind is write that
print statement for 10 times that is
print one print two print three and so
on to print ten but what if you had to
print hundred numbers
okay doable you can write the same print
statement for 100 times but what if you
had to print thousand numbers
imagine one billion can you do one
billion print statements no right so in
that scenario you can use loops so you
can just write one condition repeat this
particular print statement for one
billion times then the interpreter or
the compiler will take care of that so
that's the reason why we use loops in
java so basically we have three loops in
every programming language that is the
for loop while loop and do while loop so
a loop statement in java execute a set
of statements until a specific condition
is satisfied so here the one billion
example so here you will start from the
zeroth count so that will be the counter
variable which counts the number of
repetitions and followed by the counter
variable you will be having the
condition so you will be having the
count of variable i i is
less than or equal to the number 1
billion so until that you have to print
this particular statement and followed
by that you will be having the increment
or decrement operator in this case you
need to use the increment operator for
the first time once the print is done
you will increment the value to 2 and
the loop will be iterated once again so
this will continue the loop will iterate
itself until 1 2 3 4 so on and until it
reaches 1 billionth number so that's
when the condition fails i is greater
than or equal to 1 billion so that's
when the condition fails the condition
was to be i should be less than or equal
to 1 billion so when the number
increments above 1 billion then the
condition fails so the condition was the
number should be less than or equal to
billion but the number has exceeded the
billion so that's when the loop
terminates and executes the next
statement after the loop so i think this
was a little clear about the loop
workflow now to understand the loops in
a much more better way let's execute an
example for each one of these types of
loops so we have follow while open do
while let's execute the program for all
of these three so you can see that we
have a program on my screen so this
particular program is based on for loop
so you can see that the code part
highlighted on my editor is the follow
so you can see int i is equals to 1 so
this is the counter variable so i is the
counter variable which stores a number
from where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose zero sometimes
one or the number of your choice so here
i've chosen the number one so after the
initialization part we have the
condition part so remember the one
billionth example we discussed before so
here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10. so this particular loop
segment will run until the condition
that is i value should be less than or
equal to 10 is satisfied once it turns
false the control will exit the for loop
so that's how it's designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator once the
condition is checked the control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator and it increments
the value of 1 to 2. so this is how the
loop works now let's try to execute this
program and see the output there you go
the program got successfully executed
and the output has been printed so
basically what was the statement to be
executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator here too now
in between the printf statements we have
the value of i so in the first place i
was equals to 1 once the pre-increment
was taken place the value of i will be
increased to 2. so there you go you can
see the number 2 over there now in the
second iteration we print the value
looped two times similarly in the third
iteration looped three times so that's
how it works until the last iteration
that is looped 10 times so once the
condition is checked here the control
will enter into the next part where the
pre-increment takes place so the
pre-increment increments the value of 10
to 11. now the control will come back to
the initialization part here we have the
new value for i that is 11 now 11 will
be checked against the condition is 11
less than or equal to 10
no right so the condition here fails
now the loop is terminated the control
will exit the loop so this is how the
for loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow for a better understanding so
in this particular program we are going
to print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having even numbers and odd numbers
for example consider that you have
provided the number as five so the
numbers in between zero to five or one
to five are one two three four and five
so the four is even number and apart
from four everything else are odd
numbers so odd numbers are the numbers
which are divisible by 1 or itself so
now the sum of odd numbers is 1 plus 2
is 3 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus 5 is 11 so
that's how you print the sum of odd
numbers and the sum of even numbers that
is only four so that's how the loop
works here you have the condition if
else condition and out of that if else
condition you have the for loop so this
particular loop should be running until
a given number that will be given by you
so that's how the program works now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output so there you go the
program got successfully executed and
now it's asking for an input let's check
out five itself now you can see we have
another program on my screen which is
basically based on the same for loop so
here we have the for loop we will be
providing an input which is num and
inside that we have another condition
that is the if else loop so basically if
loop is dedicated to find out the even
numbers and l slope is dedicated to find
out the odd numbers now the whole motto
of this particular program is to find
the sum of even numbers and the sum of
odd numbers between 0 to the input
number which you provide for example
consider if we provide the number 5 as
the input then in between 0 to 5 we have
odd numbers and even numbers so the even
numbers are 2 and 4 and the odd numbers
are 1 3 and 5. so basically what happens
here is we are going to add up the
numbers so the sum of even numbers that
is 2 and 4 s 6 and sum of odd numbers
that is 5 plus 3 is 8 8 plus 1 is 9. so
that's how it should work now let's
quickly try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
program got successfully executed and
now it's asking for an input now let's
enter 5 itself and see the output so
there you go the sum of even numbers up
to 5 is 6 and the sum of odd numbers up
to 5 is 9. so this is how the program
works now apart from for loop we also
have another way to declare the same for
loop so that particular type of for loop
is called as the enhanced for loop or in
some cases it's also called as advanced
for loop let's see how the for loop is
declared in a different way so instead
of using the typical for loop which has
the initialization state then the
condition then the pre-increment or post
increment or decrement kind of
operations we simply have declared the
for and inside that we have end arr
which is the name of the variable of
arraytype and inside that we have the
array so our array consists of 10
numbers followed from 1 to 10 and now
this particular loop will execute for 10
times or until all the values in the
array are printed so now let's try to
print this so there you go the program
got successfully executed and we have
all our values from 1 to 10 which were
the input or the saved part of the array
now with this let's continue with the
next kind of loop that happens to be the
while loop so you can see an example
based on while loop on my screen so
basically everything is same uh there is
no much of a difference between for loop
and while loop but the only difference
is the keyword instead of for we have a
vial over here so
so we have the while condition over here
which says i should be less than or
equal to num divided by 2 and if this
condition is true then the control
should enter into the conditional
statement if
num modulus i is equal to equals to zero
flag is equals to true and prick so
basically the whole motto of this
program is to find out if the given
particular number is a prime number or
not now let's quickly try to run this
program and see the output now you can
see the program got successfully
executed let us try to provide a prime
number and see if the program could
identify it correctly as a prime number
or not there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number so that's how the while loop
works now let's execute another program
based on while loop but this time we
will place the condition at the end of
the loop so yeah you guessed it right
this is do while loop the only
difference between while loop and do
while loop is that
before the condition is checked in while
loop no statement is executed but it's
completely opposite when it comes to do
while loop first the program or the code
segment will be completely executed
after that the condition will be checked
surprising right let's check out the
practical part
yeah we have our program on my screen
right now so
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here so what we are going to
do is we are conveying the compiler or
the interpreter to execute this
particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between while loop and do
while loop so we have run the program
successfully and it got executed and we
were supposed to actually print the
values of i from 1 to 20 and they have
printed over here that's how it works so
what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object the object
dog has states and behaviors we can have
dogs with different breeds sizes and
colors these are considered as the
states of object dog on behavior side
dog has behavior like barking eating and
wagging tail so an object has its own
states and behaviors now let's look at
an example using java code there are
many platforms to run java program so
for this video i'll be using intellij so
let's create a new project let's name it
as project 1 and finish there we go we
have a new project with we have a class
with main and we have a main function so
the code that we write should always be
written in the main function so let's
create a new class to understand how the
object is used let's name it as student
we need variables so that we can access
the variables of this class so i am
gonna use
student id with the integer type student
name
and students age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object
of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created a object
s of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this i'll use id
and give a value similarly i'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
let's see what output will get
and there it is we have name
that's simply learn we have age and we
have id
now let us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and i'm gonna name it as
vehicles because i'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so i'm gonna use
vehicles as a combined form and yes here
we have a class main and a function main
now i need two classes for this program
so i'm gonna create two classes first
i'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class i'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in case first i need string
name
and i need the cost of the car so cost
can be integer as well because i'm gonna
use dollar sign in that so i'm gonna use
string because of that so same thing i'm
going to do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and i'm gonna name as car1 and
yes we have created the first object now
to create the second object
similarly i'm gonna create five objects
of the class cars
and i'm gonna change the name for them
so i created five objects of the same
class so i'm gonna create five objects
of the bikes class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so i'm gonna use b1
till b5
and i'm gonna name them to from b1 to b5
so now i'm going to assign values to the
variables that i created in classes bike
and cars so first i'm going to go with
cars and let's name it as lamborghini
similarly
car to ferrari
so i'm gonna use names of the cars that
are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car three
i'm gonna name it as bugatti
similarly car 4
pagani and car 5.
now i'm gonna give names for bikes
i hope everyone will understand the
names that i give
b4
and b5
last one
yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000
same b2 so b1 goes for hale davidson b2
for ducati b3 for suzuki b4 for e cos
and b5 for yamaha i'm gonna assign
values for these values accordingly for
ducati 232 000
for suzuki 200 000
300 000.
the last one yamaha 500 000
now similarly i'm gonna assign values
for carbon dot cost till cart five dot
cost
two hundred three thousand dollars for
lambo i think i can copy paste these as
well so
let's
copy paste a lot faster and easier to do
car 2 car 3
car 4 and car 5
we don't need this
as per car 2 let's take it as 252
000 and
let's make it it's 3 million
as per this let's keep it as
1 million
four hundred thousand and lastly uh
let's see is 293 now that we have
assigned all the values for all this now
let's print it and get the value i'm
going to create a very simple program
but a very user friendly program so it's
gonna be interesting for you guys so we
are going to ask the users what would
they like either bikes or cars so we
need to give them the options and our
next program will be based on the
options that the users select not the
options we give as the command so let's
do it
let's give the options
one
[Music]
bikes
and 2 cars
i need to take the value that user gives
for this i am going to write this
command
so i have not used scanner yet so let's
import
scanner
and let's create a object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
i'm using next int if the data type was
string then i would have used next line
so now that we have choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here i am giving options to the users so
that they can choose easily from number
1 to 5.
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that i'm gonna ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice i'm going to use one
more variable let's say n so i'm going
to store n
if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
harley davidson then i am going to show
the cost of harley davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means ducati so we have
to show the rate of ducati or the cost
of ducati to the user
now similarly i am going to do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and n is
equal to 5.
now i am gonna do for n is equal to four
and lastly n is equal to 5 that is a
last bike yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between 1 to five so for that i am
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
one and five
so now we have code for bikes and the
same thing whatever the user selects
that he wants to find the car so for
that we have this the choice is equal to
is equal to 1 so the same thing we are
going to do for choice is equal to is
equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have five models
the same names that i gave to variables
i am going to give this to here
second one ferrari
third book rt
fourth e cos
and the last one
[Music]
posh
now we are going to ask the users their
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
i am going to use c
now if c is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of lamborghini that he puts the choice
as one so we're going to display this
message the cost of lamborghini
and we are going to use else if loop to
enter the next values for c from 1 to 5
if c is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice
then we go for e-course
and the last one if user enters the
choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from 1 to 5 then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between
one to five now remember the first
choice that we wanted from user to enter
either bikes or cars so what if the user
do not enter either one or two so for
that we need one more else function to
tell the user that either enter one or
two
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus f10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program let's test this program now
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have five models harley
davidson ducati suzuki pagani and yamaha
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have a result the cost of
harley davidson is 130 000 dollars
so with this we have completed our code
and please feel free to type this code
in your own computer and try out all the
permutation and combinations that you
can with this program so with this let's
move on to classes and understand the
classes and their concept then we'll
have a new program on classes now let's
see what is a class a class is a
blueprint from which objects are created
a class describes state or behavior of
an object in this example dog is a class
the variables in this class are breed
and color the functions or methods of
the class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class
main now let's create some classes to do
code on
i'll create a new java class as cars
and then i'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so i'm gonna connect cars and bikes with
automobiles so that we can use that
program in main and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles i need some variables
i'll take private double and let's say
fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string
and brand now let's have getters and
setters for this so these are used to
get the value and set the value for the
variables inside the class
there we go
we have the getters and setters for it
now let's go to class cars
so public class cars extends automobiles
so in it i'm gonna create one more class
or a constructor
and i'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created car has been
created now the same thing i'm gonna do
with bikes let's go to bikes and
i'm gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles
this is because i can inherit all the
variables from the automobiles class
so i created a constructor and i'm gonna
print a message
a new bike has been created
so i have created class cars bikes and
automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so i'm going to start with the code
now it's a very simple code i'm going to
first i'm going to create
the variables or the objects of the
class
with private
bikes bike so one is car and one is bike
both are objects for the classes so i'm
going to use this objects
bikes bike
is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now i am going to run it
it'll take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that i typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes
so i'm going to bikes
so i'm going to create a new method or a
new function
public void cake for bike so i'm going
to print message
the bike has been started with kick
bike has been started
with kick now the same thing i'm gonna
do with cars now how does a car start
with the key so i'm gonna make a
function public key and inside it i'm
gonna print the same message car has
been started with key i should write
void there to give the return value as
wide
so let's print the message
car has been started
with key rotation let's write that as
well so in the main program i'm gonna
use objects to use those functions and
let's see what changes they'll do to our
program
pike dot cake and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go first we used to have
this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked those functions and methods
that are there in class cars and bikes
so if i write bike dot key
or
car dot kick
this won't work this is because key is
not a method of bike or kik is not a
method of car so that's why i gave
private
static for the functions
so if i execute it these are the error
messages that i'll get cannot find the
symbol method kick or method key what is
an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract class or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirement
so abstract class in java is considered
as a template of methods and variables
which are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly now moving ahead
we will next learn the important
features of abstract classes
so the first one is template
the main reason programmers prefer to
use abstract methods is because they act
as a predefined template
for any future specific class that you
might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that
we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not the least
dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overridden method is resolved at runtime
this is how java implements runtime
polymorphism
when an overridden method is called by
reference
java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
all right let us go through the rules
one by one as mentioned below
the first one is
the keyword abstract is mandatory to
declare an abstract class followed by
that the next rule says that abstract
classes cannot be instantiated directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods
next an abstract class
may also include non-abstract methods
it's not mandatory that an abstract
class should only include abstract
methods
so the last rule says that an abstract
class can include constructors and
static methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class then
after that we declare the name of our
class
the name of the class is up to the
user's choice for example i have named
my class as simply learn as shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now i have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
choice as you can see i have used
simplylearn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstract last
method the next one is by using an
interface method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary between the method and the
class implementing it in java we use
interface to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax to use an interface to
achieve abstraction in java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword call interface followed by that
we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example i have named my class
as simply learn as shown below
as discussed earlier interface acts just
as a container that stores only the
signatures of the method
we cannot have a complete method defined
inside it
all we can do is just declare an
interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface
let us look into some example programs
based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
eclipse ide now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this
process as you can see the project has
been successfully created and inside the
project simply learn we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a drop box where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class and the name
of this particular class will be person
which will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person and
this person class will be inherited by
the employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output to execute the
program just right click on the package
and go to the run option and select the
first one that is java
application now you can see we have the
employee named pavitra
and the gender is female and the
employee has logged in successfully so
these are the details which we were
expecting to be presented on the output
console
now moving ahead we shall execute our
next example which will be based on
students
so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely raju pranita and punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student
is being declared using the keyword
abstract and inside that we have an
abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are
raju pranita and punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract class named
loan and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes andhra
bank bank of baroda idbc bank state bank
of india which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword
while we declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface
on the other hand when we declare an
abstract class we use the keyword
abstract
followed by that the second difference
is
when you use an interface the subclasses
basically implement an interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both is interface is capable to support
multiple inheritance
whereas on the other hand abstract
classes are not capable to support
multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes
the abstract classes avoid code
duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage
and finally the last advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract losses
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class in java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is
object relational impedance mismatch in
the case of rdbms and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of frameworks like
hibernate
so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule
now the question is why do we need
encapsulation the main reasons are first
better control of class attributes and
methods second class attributes can be
made read-only or write-only third it
makes java code very flexible this means
the programmer can change one part of
the code without affecting other parts
apart from these encapsulation is mainly
used to protect data and increase
security of the code as you can see to
protect the data variables must be
private and they can only be accessed
through methods now let's see java code
for encapsulation to understand the
concept better so now let's create a new
project
next
next
and i'm gonna name it as
ncap1
so here we have a main class
we can write the code here so before i
take the code let me create a new class
right click new java class
and i'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee
using employee name id and salary so in
this class let me create variables
first string name
then
integer id
and then in salary
so i can easily use these variables in a
main program by creating object of the
class so let me just create the object
employee e is equal to new employee
now i can use e dot id name or salary
anything i need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured
so for that i'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so i
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if i write id
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see id has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need
getters and setters that are normally
methods that are used for these so right
click
generate
and here you can see getters and setters
so just select all of them
and ok
so now we can use these methods instead
of direct using the variables so we can
get in the starting then set then get
and again set so likewise it goes like
this
so now we have set here so
if i want to declare variable and if i
want to put some value inside my
variable so how can i do that
here you can see get id or get salary so
if i go for get id sorry if i go for e
dot set id and i set it as 6
so
this shows no error this means we can
use methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first i'm gonna
set everything
and lastly e dot set salary let's get it
as 30 000
maybe in dollars or maybe in rupees
let's just set it as 30 000 for now
so how i'm gonna print it for this i'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and e dot not set name but this time i'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that i have
given so in this case that's simply
learn
and next will be id
and e dot get id
and lastly
salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn id
6 and salary is 30 000
so i hope you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we use getters and setters that are
inbuilt functions for intellij or
netbeans or eclipse so with this let's
move on to our next program to
understand it better and how we can
manipulate these variables or methods
using program
so again let's create a new project
and this time i'm going to name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program
now this time i'm going to use an
example of cars so let me just create a
new class and i'm gonna name it as cars
so in this again i'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first i'm gonna get string name
then private string
price
that means price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but i'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so i'm gonna
create a constructor for the class cars
and inside i'm gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string price
and string top speed
and i'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it
so similarly i'm gonna give it as this
dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate
getter and setter
select all and ok
this is a great feature that we have in
java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first i'll
create object of the class cars
and inside this i'm gonna give arguments
or inside this i'm gonna give values
that i use in constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or c dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as bmw
the second thing was price so i'm gonna
give it as thirty thousand dollars
and the third one was top speed so top
speed i'm gonna give it as
200 kilometer per hour so we have
assigned all the values to the variables
and we have created object as well all
in the same line so this is another way
of creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private
so if i try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and c dot
so this time i'm gonna give get name so
it automatically gets the value that i
assigned to the variables through
getters and setters
after that price
price c dot price get price
and in the end
top speed
c dot get top speed
so if i print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name bmw price
and even the top speed now if i give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go
name bmw price 30 000 and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any getters or setters so in this
method we used only getters to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them
now for this again i can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is
so c dot set price
so price i'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand dollars
and c dot set top speed let me increase
it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that i'm so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old i'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if i print these values i'm just
gonna copy paste it
so now if i print it let's execute it
and here you go
first we have name price and top speed
then stats after updations that means
after we set the value the value gets
overwritten on the variables and now we
have a new price and top speed and all
the details so this is how you can
manipulate variables or values inside
the variables now let's see what is
inheritance when one class inherits some
properties and attributes of other class
it is known as inheritance let's have a
look at an example in this example
mobiles is of superclass that have
variables like cost color and ram the
classes that inherits the variables and
methods of mobiles are samsung xiaomi
and nokia these classes are known as
subclass now let's see the types of
inheritance in java
first we have single inheritance in
single inheritance one class inherits
features from another class as you can
see above class b inherits all
properties of class a this is a simple
concept of inheritance next we have
multi-level inheritance a derived class
inherits from base class and derived
class also act as a base class to other
class sounds complicated right now see
this example class b is derived from
class a then class c is derived from
class b because of this class c contains
properties of both class a and b this is
very effective when you go for
inheritance in big programs and lastly
we have hierarchical inheritance in this
one class serves as base class and two
or more classes serves as derived class
as you can see above class b class d and
class c have a single base class a so
three classes inherits properties of
single class this is called hierarchical
inheritance now to understand these all
concepts better let's use java code
so now let's create a new project
next
next
and i'm gonna name it as inheritance
so we have our main program here so i'll
just create a new class
new java class and for now let me just
name it as mobiles
so what are the features in mobiles to
start with
the cost of the mobile
the color of the mobile
and what can we do it as our ram of the
mobile
i am making it as string because i'm
going to write gb as well so that's why
string
and now let's use getters and setters
for this
select all
and okay
so we have our first class mobiles here
so our first type of inheritance was
single inheritance so i'll create one
more class
and i'm gonna name it as android
and i'll make android as
extends okay i'll leave it for now so
this mobile class we are going to use
afterwards for now i'll use only android
so
let me make it as string
android
version
and for this i'm gonna go for getter and
setter
so what is single level inheritance one
class inherits from another class so
i'll create one more program or i'll
create a one more class and i'm gonna
name it as
samsung because samsung is an android
phone and as well as it comes under
mobiles so now i'm gonna extend it to
android
extends android so no need of writing
anything inside it as soon as i write
extends android i can use all the
variables right now i have only android
version as the variable
so now let's go to main program
and i'm right samsung s is equal to new
samsung
so i just created an object of it
so now if i use s dot i'll get android
version so i'll set android version as
android
pie
and now to show it
i'm gonna give it as
samsung
android version
and here s dot
get android version
so now i have android class and a
samsung class and i extended android
class to the samsung so samsung can use
all the variables here and i can even
set the variables here so if i execute
it
and here you go you can see samsung
android version that's android pie
so without even declaring even a single
variable or method here in samsung i use
the variable of android and i did this
so this is called as single level
inheritance so next i'm gonna move it
for multi-level inheritance so what is
multi-level one class is derived from
next and this class is derived from here
so i have three classes right now so i'm
gonna put android
extends
mobile
so now android can use all the variables
of mobiles i can use cost color or ram
and even samsung that extends android
can use all the variables from mobile so
if i put variables for it
s dot see i can get color cost or ram so
i'm gonna go for set color
i'm gonna give it as black
and next
s dot
set cost cost i'm gonna give it as 30
000 let it be dollar or rupees
and the last one s dot
ram
i'm gonna give it as
4 gb
so now if i print
i'll just delete all this
so now i can print them one by one so
let's just do that
so i'm gonna give it a samsung mobile
details
and then
cost
s dot get cost
next i'm gonna give it as color
plus s dot color
sorry s dot get color
and next last one i'm gonna give it as
ram
plus s dot get ram
so now you can see i have not declared
any variable inside samsung but i
inherited all the variables from here
mobiles and android so all the variables
from mobiles are here and as per android
if i put
android version
s dot get
android version
so now if i execute it i'll get all the
values and as a result i'll get
everything that i gave as the value
so now let's just execute it
oh instead of cost i should put color
so as you can see i have the cost of
samsung mobile color and ram and even
android version so all these variables i
gave in mobile and android version i
gave in android class
but nothing in samsung class so this is
how multi-level inheritance works so now
let's move on to the third topic that
was hierarchical inheritance so what is
hierarchical in inheritance in that
three classes or two classes have a
single base class so i'm gonna create
two more classes that derives android so
now let's create them
next i'm gonna name it as nokia
and the last one
xiaomi
so these are real time examples three
mobiles we have three different
companies and all uses android and they
all come under mobiles
so now in everything i'm gonna write
extends android
so this is the final version of
inheritance that we have and this is
very simple to understand but it might
get complicated when we use big programs
or very large programs for some project
so now i have nothing inside class nokia
or xiaomi or samsung i'm gonna use all
the variables that come from android and
mobiles as android extends mobiles so
this is the concept like i have three
classes three mobile companies that
comes under android and we can use them
to manipulate the variables and assign
values to the variables so i already
have everything from samsung
so first let's create objects for all
these classes
nokia n is equal to new nokia
and xiaomi x is equal to new
so now i'm going to assign variables to
their values so now let's start with
nokia
n dot
set color
let's give it as red
n dot set cost i'm gonna give it as
forty thousand
again doesn't matter because it's a
normal program so it doesn't matter
whether it's dollar or
rupees so next n dot
set ram
ram 4 gb
and lastly n dot set android version
android marshmallow
so and in the end i'm gonna give x dot
let's just copy paste it
so it will be lot easier for
me to code or for you to code
so here x start
and color i'm gonna give it as
silver
rate 50 000 ram 6gb
and android let's give it some old
so
get get
so now we have set all the values to the
variables so now let's print them as
well so again i'm gonna copy paste all
those details
instead of samsung nokia
here it gets n
n
instead of s
and now again copy paste
now xiaomi
x dot
x dot
x and finally x so with this i have
completed the program i can show you all
the
values that i gave in the starting let's
just revise it
so in mobiles i gave all the variables
cost color and ram android i extended
from mobiles and i gave one more
variable as android version
nokia xiaomi and samsung i gave nothing
but i only extended android
so now let's execute it
so we have successfully executed our
program let's have a look at it
so here samsung mobile details in the
starting color cost after that
nokia mobiles and in the end xiaomi
mobile and everything that we gave as
the value are here so with this we have
completed our program i hope you
understood what inheritance is so i'll
just revise it one more time so in
single level inheritance i used only
samsung android and mobiles and samsung
i derived from android and i used only
android version in the starting next i
used multi-level inheritance in that i
used mobile's android and samsung
with the use of mobile variables
i use samsung and i printed the values
of color cost ram and android version as
samsung
in the next that is hierarchical
inheritance i use nokia xiaomi and
samsung
what is polymorphism according to
chemistry the term polymorphism can be
defined as the ability of any element or
compound to exist in multiple
crystalline forms this is called
polymorphism for example if you have the
carbon atom it can come out in different
forms in coal graphite and diamond
what is polymorphism in java
similarly in the terms of java
programming language polymorphism is
defined as the ability of any object in
clat in a class
to perform a particular task in multiple
methods
this is known as polymorphism in java
we're going to open up our eclipse
editor and we're going to do some animal
sounds with cows cats and dogs just kind
of a fun almost kids-like
example of polymorphism and you can see
i already have my inheritance in here
let's go ahead and create a new
uh package
and we'll call this polymorphism
just to keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're going to go ahead and add a
class in
and if you were doing
an abstract class we could label it as
abstract we're not going to directly
access it and we'll call it animal
sounds maybe we will we'll see how we
load the
program app but we'll call this animal
sounds
and let's create a public it's not going
to return anything but we'll call it
sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a
system out
print and with our system out print line
we'll just have it say animals
make
different
sounds
there we go
so yeah it's really simple and
straightforward we're just gonna have it
print something out
and if we're gonna do that let's go
ahead and just um a good thing i didn't
make it abstract let's go ahead and just
test it out and see what it looks like
and we'll do um oh we'll call it animal
main animal
maine
and in here let's go ahead and test out
what we just put together
uh we'll do our our static void main so
it's going to run on here and we'll
create our animal
sounds
we'll call it animal because we don't
know what kind of animal this is we'll
call it new animal
sounds
and we'll just take that animal
um and i like to
put it in capitalize but usually we'd
like to do this lowercase
there we go
and we'll just have our
animal
uh dot
sound
and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
comes out
we can see here animals make different
sounds okay that's not too exciting
so let's jump in there and let's say we
have
in this case we're going to add in a
couple of different animals
we'll add in a
oh let's start with a
cow yeah why not a cow
so we'll have our cow in here we'll go
ahead and click ok
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually
makes us you know a very clear noise so
we'll go ahead and give the cow a sound
and we'll have the cow
say moo moo and the cow is going to
extend
there's our um
and we'll put in our extends animal
sounds and then i want to go back here
to our animal main
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal maine we want to do
cow
cow
equals new
cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds
there we go
and we run this
you can see it comes out here and it
says the cow says moo moo
so if we go back to cal we're just going
to do this real quick
and let's say
we just take this out of here the public
void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal main and run that
recompiles animals make different sounds
because it doesn't know what sound a cow
makes
so this is really central to
polymorphism is we're taking something
going on in the um
in one set up that we've brought in and
extended from our animal sounds and
we've changed it to the cow says mumu
and we can also add in multiple animals
in here we'll go ahead and just add in
one more animal uh we'll call this one
we'll do a dog why not
so here comes in our dog
and of course we want the dog to
actually say something
and we'll have the dog
go bow wow and then we'll go back to our
animal main we have to create a dog
and we'll say cow
simply dog dog
upper case for the class lower case for
the actual object
and then of course we need the dog
to make a sound so we'll go down here
and go dog dot
sound
and when we run this as you expect the
it's going to compile it there we go
animals making different sounds the cow
says moo moo the dog says bow wow
characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member of method in a class with
different types
which we'll cover briefly in a minute
polymorphism supports implicit type
conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism run time
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time that's
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time
in method overloading in java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared
we'll now execute a program based on the
functionality of additional operator in
a different situation and let's flip
back on over to our eclipse
so in here i'm going to go back under
the dog
and let me just highlight this
and we're going to do the same thing so
you see right here it says public void
sound so this is identical public void
sound
but instead of sending uh nothing we're
going to send it a string we're going to
call it angry
now at this point
you should note that what if it's a
happy dog i would have to add an if then
if the string angry said happy then we'd
print happy or something else but we're
just keeping it simple so we've entered
another sound identical to the first but
we've added string angry to it and this
is going to print out the dog says growl
growl now if we go back to our animal
mane
and here's our dog same dog
same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here
and we put that string in here we'll go
ahead and just call it angry it doesn't
really matter what string you put in
here because we haven't sorted out what
the string means
for now it just says growl growl it's
going to recompile it so remember this
is a polymorphism during compile time
and here we have it the dog says
growlgrowl the duck says bow wow and
then the angry dog says growlgrowl so
there is another
thing called operator overloading
operator overloading is not supported in
java
authors of java wanted to keep the
language less complicated
explaining operator overloading it
basically is a way of bundling
operations into the call statement and
user procedures it's so that it looks
like a math on a paper you have a plus
add b plus c kind of thing and it's all
wrapped up in your call to another
statement this just gets confusing it
really isn't necessary so the driver
developers decided not to put it in
there so runtime polymorphism in java
programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage here the
overriding method gets resolved in
execution
so far we've talked about compile time
polymorphism as you saw in the program
we just wrote when it's compiling it
does the extend and figures out which
overload method to use on there
in runtime polymorphism method
overriding in java the method
overwriting is a procedure where child
class is allowed to implement a specific
class that is already provided in the
parent class
for runtime compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go ahead and
introduce the super key word now from
inheritance you should remember that we
can
look at super from before but we're
going to use it slightly different it's
kind of doing the same thing as when we
did the inheritance but we're doing like
what they call an override during run
time so the term super is predefined
keyword in java that is used to refer
the immediate parent class object or
method defined in the program
in this procedure whenever you create an
instance of subclass then automatically
an instance of parent is also created
that will be implicitly referred by the
super reference variable
so going back into our animal sounds
let's go in here to dog
and if we add a super dot
sound
in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is because we
extends the dog extends animal sounds
and so here's our super dot sound
and if we go ahead and both run and
compile this
and you can see here that it comes down
and says the dog says growl growl
because that's what we had it um system
out print line to
and then the super animals make
different sounds and so if we go back to
our animal mane
this is what it's calling right here
it's going back into sound under the
animal mains and it's printing out or
doing whatever it does here at this
point we usually have it return
something so you can look up whatever
the original class was using
so getting back to
these two setups whether you're using
the super to use a runtime polymorphism
because that's what's happening during
run time versus compile time
polymorphism during compile time
polymorphism method call is handled by
the compiler itself so the programs
maybe take them a second more to compile
but it runs faster in the run time the
method call cannot be handled by
compiler in the execution stage so if
you have any errors it's not going to
show up either during the compile time
we have compile time polymorphism is
less flexible as it needs handle all
method calls in compile time so you
really in runtime polymorphism your it
exhibits higher flexibility as a method
call gets handled at runtime coming in
the execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less
that's what it's just talking about it
compiles it so the compiling takes maybe
a little bit more but if you're
executing the same program over and over
and over again once it's distributed
it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script a
thousand times suddenly that .01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
thousand iterations uh then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in runtime integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in run time again it's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre-mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overriding
advantages of polymorphism programmers
code can be reused via polymorphism
number one goal of a programmer is to
reuse the code as much as possible so
you're not reinventing the will over and
over again
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities
and some of the disadvantages of
polymorphism that can come up is that
polymorphism ends up raising performance
issues in real time
you can see whereas you're loading all
these different things you might end up
creating loops you didn't know you're
doing polymorphism reduces readability
of the code sometime your actual code
everything you look at in java is
polymorphism all based on a primary
object so you could have a very
complicated setup and then it actually
is very easy to read when you actually
put your final variable in there but
when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you loop
through all these different inherited
modules or classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is choose from over 300 in demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
what exactly is a java collection
a java collection can be generally
defined as a collective unit of objects
in the form of a group
for example a group of numbers of
integer data type etc moving forward
we enter into our next topic where we
face the java collections framework this
will help us understand java collections
in a little more detailed way
a java collection framework represents a
unified architecture for storing and
manipulating a group of objects its
architecture includes the following
an interface a class and the java
collections api
to understand these in a much better way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy the utility
package java.util contains all the
classes and interfaces that are required
by a collection framework the collection
framework contains an interface named as
an iterable interface which provides the
iterator to iterate through all the
collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface which acts as
a root for the collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator and the
methods of this interface
the following figure illustrates the
hierarchy of collection framework out of
the complexities we have the interface
and the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time as you can see on
the screen we have the iterable class
which is implemented by the collection
class and this particular collection
class is further implemented by list
queue and set and moving ahead we have
the following classes which have
implemented the list queue and set
classes in the list we have array list
linked list vector stack and on the
other hand on the queue we have priority
queue dq and array dq and finally on the
set we have the hash set lint hash set
sorted set preset etc now moving further
we will enter our first java collection
which is none other than the interface
so the first one is an interface an
interface can have methods and variables
but the methods declared in an interface
are by default abstract that is only the
method signature is available not the
body
interfaces specify what a class must do
and not how it must do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection is a foundation to the java
collections framework note that all the
collection interfaces are generic for
example public interface collection is
the syntax for the generics and when we
declare the collection we should use it
to specify the type of object which it
can contain
it helps in reducing runtime errors by
type checking the objects at compile
time to keep the number of core
collections interface manageable the
java platform doesn't provide separate
interfaces for each variant of each
collection type if an unsupported
operation is invoked a collection
implementation throws an unsupported
operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces that we should use
for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are set
interface list interface dq interface q
interface map interface sorted set
interface
sorted map interface
no worry those are a lot of interfaces
but we will discuss each one of them in
a detailed way along with a practical
example for a better understanding
so the first one in the docket is the
set interface a set is a collection that
cannot contain any duplicate elements
this interface model is the mathematical
set abstraction and is used to represent
sets such as a deck of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose set implementations
the hash set tree set and
linked hash set the set interface does
not allow random access to an element in
the collection you can use an iterator
for each loop to traverse elements of a
set
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical example i have
prepared a code document for all the
programs that i am going to explain to
just save time you can always have
access to it all you need to do is just
ask for it in the comment section below
so you can see on my screen we have an
example for set interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23 43
53 22 and 65. so let's try to execute
this program and see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53 22 and 23
43 so the sorted set is here which is a
21 22 23 43 53 and 65
and the first element being 21 and the
last element being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next type of interface which is
none other than the list interface so
what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain duplicate elements you
can access any element from its index
the list is more likely an
array with dynamic length the list is
one of the most used collection types
and array list and linked list are the
implementation classes of the list
interface
the list interface provides useful
methods to add an element at a specific
index to remove and replace elements
based on the index and to get a sub list
using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list interface so we are going to add in
three names which are david john and
stacy into our list and also we have a
fourth edition
which is stacy again
just to check if the statement is true
it says
list interface also allows duplicate
elements unlike the set interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david john and stacy are added into the
list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this comment and try to run again
and check if the fourth element which is
the duplicate of the third stacy
will be added into the list or not so as
you can see the program was successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy the duplication of the first one
got successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into our next type
of interface
which is the queue interface so what
exactly is a queue interface q is a
collection used to hold multiple
elements prior to processing
besides basic collection operations a
queue provides additional insertion
extraction and inspection operations
cues typically but did not necessarily
order elements in the fifo or first in
first out manner
among the exceptions are priority cues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is the element that would be
removed by a call to remove or poll in a
first and first out cue
all new elements are inserted at the
tail of the cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for queue interface
so in this particular queue we are going
to store the names of fruits apple mango
grapes and banana and apple being the
head of the queue and banana being the
tail of the queue
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first after that
we are going to remove the element
grapes from the queue
so the command is q dot remove the
element name so after that the grapes
element has been removed from our queue
we have the latest size of the queue as
three
now after that we are also going to
check if the element apple is included
in the queue are not so for that
statement
yes the element apple is included in the
queue and the result is true so this is
how the cues work and let's move further
and in the next phase we have the dq
interface so what exactly is a dq
interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion and removal at both
the ends is called as a dq interface
the name dq is short for double ended q
and is usually pronounced as dec most dq
implementations place no fixed limits on
the number of elements they may contain
but this interface supports capacity
restricted dqs as well as those with no
fixed size limit this interface defines
methods to access the elements at both
the ends of the dq
methods are provided to insert remove
and examine the element for a better
understanding let's check out an example
so you can see on my screen we have a
program for dq interface so here we are
going to add in some elements into our
dq and then also try to remove the first
element and print the updated dq
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so as you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the elements which we tried to push
into the dq
52 10 and 21 52 is being the first
element and the 21 is being the last
element so we try to remove the first
element which is the 52
so after that the updated dq is having
two elements which are 10 and 21
so this is how the queues work now let's
move ahead and learn our next type of
interface which is the map interface so
what exactly is a map interface a java
map is an object that maps keys along
with its values a map cannot contain
duplicate keys each key
can map to at most one value
the java platform contains three general
purpose map implementations which are
the hash map tree map and linked hash
map
the basic operations of a map are
contains key contains value size and is
empty for a better understanding let us
check out an example so this particular
example on my screen is an example
for map interface here we are going to
add three elements and map them as one
as cricket two as hockey and three as
archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are
mapped with their keys and the element
cricket is mapped with the key one and
similarly hockey with k2 and r3 with k3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move further into our next
type of interface which is the sorted
set interface so what exactly is a
sorted set interface so a sorted set is
a set that maintains its elements in
ascending order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as
word list and membership roles
for a better understanding let's check
out an example based on sorted set
interface
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to print the same
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and we have our
elements printed in the sorted set and
you can see the
names have been arranged in the form of
ascending order according to the
alphabets which have started in the
first position so this is exactly how
the sort set interface works
so the last one in the interfaces is the
sorted map interface a map that
maintains its mapping in an ascending
key order
this is the map analog of sorted set the
certain maps are used for naturally
audit collections of key value pairs
such as dictionaries and telephone
directories
now for a better understanding let's
check out an example based on map
interface or sorted map interface so you
can see the program on my screen is an
example for sorted map interface
so here we are going to add in the
elements john molly aaron and daisy into
the map interface now along with the
names we also have their aggregates
which is
76.5 for john 87.3 for molly and 78.2
for aaron and for
daisy we have 73.4
now finally we are going to fetch the
data of molly which is the aggregate of
molly now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and molly's
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our next topic
which is the java collection classes so
now that we have finished the java
collection interfaces let us have a
quick understanding of java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method the add method is used to add an
object to the collection and next is the
easempty method
this method returns to true if the
collection contains no elements followed
by that we have the clear method and
this method is used to remove all the
elements from the collection followed by
that we have the remove method this
method is used to remove the given
object from the collection if there are
duplicate values then this method
removes the first occurrence of the
object next to the remove method we have
the size method so the size method is
used to return the number of elements in
the collection so after the size method
we have the stream method
the stream method is used to return a
sequential stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is the two array
method
so the two array method is used to
return an array containing all the
elements in this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method this method is used to return the
hashcode value for this collection
next the equals method
the equals method is used to compare the
specified object with the remaining
elements in the collection
followed by that we have the iterator
method so the iterator method is used as
an iterator over the elements of the
particular collection and finally we
have the contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element is existing in the
collection and false if it is not
present so with this we finish the
collection interface and collection
interface methods now we will move ahead
into our next topic which is none other
than the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class a class is a user
defined blueprint or prototype from
which objects are created it represents
a set of properties or methods that are
common to all the objects of one type
now we'll start up with the first one
which is the hash set class so the java
hash set is the basic implementation of
the set interface that is backed up by
the hash map it makes no guarantee for
the iteration order
of the set and permits null elements as
well
so this class offers constant time
performance for basic operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets we can set the initial
capacity and load factor for this
collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before its
capacity is automatically increased
for a better understanding let's go
through an example
so on my screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes along with null
values
so we have added in two null values to
just check if it allows two null values
at once
so basically it only should allow one
null value so let's check out how does
it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the null value
is stored only once that two in the
first location
so this is how the hash set classes work
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class which is the tree set
class
so a tree set class is a navigable set
implementation based on a tree map the
elements are ordered using their natural
ordering or by a comparator provided at
set creation time depending on which
constructor is being used this
implementation provides guaranteed log
stein cost for the basic operations such
as add remove and contains
note that the ordering maintained by a
set whether or not an explicit
comparator is provided must be
consistent with equals if it is to
correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example now we are
going to add in some numbers into the
tree set using the add method now let's
execute this code and see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set and the numbers are
ordered in ascending order
which is 0 18 88 748
983 8476
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is
the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array that is an implementation of list
interface that allows null elements so
in this class we have three types of
arrays which are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays now let's check
out the one-dimensional array
so
a one-dimensional array looks similar to
this where we have the array index
and the element present in the array so
here our indexes are a0 1 2 3 and 4 and
the elements which are shown here to
understand one dimensional arrays in a
much better way let's go through a
sample program
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for one dimensional
array and we are going to store the
elements 10 20 and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one dimensional
area
moving further we will discuss the two
dimensional arrays the two-dimensional
arrays are completely similar to
one-dimensional array but the only
difference is the index numbers earlier
we had index number but now we have
index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements in a matrix form
so to understand this in a much better
way let's go through a sample code so
you can see this particular program in
my screen is an example for
two-dimensional arrays so here we are
going to add in elements one two three
and four in the matrix form and we are
going to use two for loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output
so you can see we have the elements 1 2
3 and 4 and the elements are printed in
the matrix form
at the array index location 0 0 we have
1 0 1 we have 2 and 1 0 we have 3 and 1
1 we have 4 so this is how the two
dimensional arrays work and finally
let's deal with the third type of array
which is the multi-dimensional or
three-dimensional array
so you can see the three-dimensional
array is completely similar or a little
bit similar to the two-dimensional array
but the only difference is we have a
third vector here
so next up we have the linked list
linked lists also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list doubly
linked list and circular linked list
now let's check out each one of those
so the first one is the single linked
list so you can see in a singly linked
list each memory segment is divided into
two parts so the first half of the
memory location is given for the element
and the second half of the memory
location is dedicated for the address so
this particular address is used to point
to the next element or the next memory
allocation which stores the second
element similarly the third so this is
how the singly linked list works so the
last memory or location is called as
tail and the last address will not store
nothing but null which indicates the end
of the singly linked list
now to understand single linked list in
a much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list now
we are going to add in the elements 1 2
3 and 4 in the form of a singly linked
list now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are 1 2 3 and 4. now let's move further
and try to learn the next type of linked
list which is the doubly linked list
so the doubly linked list is completely
similar to that of the singly linked
list but the only difference is we have
two address locations so the first
address location of the head stores null
and the last address location of the
tail stores null which
indicate the start and end of the doubly
linked list respectively
so here in the second memory location
you have two addresses so the first
address points to the previous element
and the next address points to the next
element so to understand doubly linked
list in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for doubly linked
list and we have the node which has the
data and previous address next address
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output and the elements that
we are going to store in this particular
doubly linked list are one two three
four and five
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the notes are
one two three and four and five so this
is how the w link lists to work and now
let's check out the third type of linked
list which is the circular linked list
so there are similarities between the
previous linked list and the circular
linked list
so the circular linked list makes it
circular based on the last address
location
so this particular address location
points to the first element back again
so this is how it becomes a circular
linked list so to understand this in a
much better way let's check out an
example for it
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for circular linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output so you can see we have
successfully included one two three four
five six and seven and eight into our
circular linked list and they are
printed on the screen so this is how the
circular linked list work so moving
further we will try to understand the
next type of classes in java collections
which is the hashmap class so hash table
is based on the implementation of map
interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key hashmap class is
roughly equivalent to hash table except
that it is unsynchronized and permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map now for a better
understanding let's go through a sample
program
so this particular
program on my screen is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer and their bike so let's
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
manufacturer and their mate bikes now
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class in java collection
which is the tree map class so the tree
map is based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at map
creation time depending on the
constructor used
now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the roll numbers and the
names of students here now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console
so we have the roll numbers of the
students and their names amber
james wallet and reynolds along with
their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms so the first one is sorting
sorting does the job of ascending and
descending numbers based on the
algorithm written by the user for a
simple example we shall consider the
bubble sort algorithm for this one so
you can see on my screen we have an
example for bubble sort algorithm so we
have the elements 289 39 48 6 28 1 2 and
33 which are ordered in
an orderly manner let's try to execute
this program and order them
so you can see array before bubble sort
is 289 38 48 similarly 33 and after the
bubble sort we have the sorted array
which is 1 2 6 28 33 39 48 and 289 so
this is how the bubble sort works now
let's move further and understand the
next type of api
which is the shuffling algorithm
so the shuffling algorithms are designed
to destroy the current arrangements they
are employed on creating randomness in
the list so for a better understanding
let's check out an example so you can
see the program written on my screen is
an example for shuffle algorithm so we
have an array which has the elements
completely sorted in ascending order
which is 10 to 100.
now when we run the shuffle algorithm
these elements will be completely
shuffled according to a random order now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
elements which were in an ascending
order are now completely in disorder so
this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further and
understand the next type of algorithm
which is the searching algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example let's use the
binary search
now you can see a program on my screen
which is an example for binary search so
we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array now what we are going to do is
search for the element or the key
element 2 in our array using the binary
search algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says the element which you are looking
for is found in the index location one
so this is how the binary search
algorithm works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the composition
algorithm so the definition says the
frequency and disjoint algorithms test
some aspect of composition of one or
more collections so the frequency counts
the number of times the specified
element occurs in the specified
collection so the disjoint determines
whether two collections are disjoint
that is whether they contain no element
in common or not now to understand it in
a much better way let's go through an
example so you can see on my screen
there is an example for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and
the elements are completely disjoint now
moving further we will enter into our
next topic which is based on the
benefits of java collections so there
are various benefits of java collections
out of those the major benefits are
software or code reusability so the java
collections enable code reusability to
save time followed by that the ease of
designing apis so the next two ease of
designing apis we have the simplicity in
learning and using apis and finally
increased speed in programming so these
were the major benefits of java
collections what is an exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program
this may not be considered merely as an
error but it surely does impact the
normal functioning of the program
segment
now these types of exceptions are
resolved by the most efficient mechanism
called exception handling
exception handling is not any rocket
science but a simple mechanism that
drives the compiler to the next
statement by making the compiler
understand that the input obtained or
the malfunction that arise is just an
unexpected or an unnecessary event which
can be ignored by sending the user with
a relevant message about the exception
arrows
for a better understanding let us go
through a small example
so as you can see on our screen we have
typed in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data.txt from the c drive so this
particular data.txt is not really
existing in the c drive so when we run
this program we will face an exception
that says file is not found so let's try
to run this program and see
so as expected
so when we run this program we get that
this particular file what you're looking
for which is data.txt is not found
or in other words it is not present in
the specified location
so this is how the exceptions work in
java
now followed by this we will move ahead
into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error
so what exactly is an error
so here we are trying to learn about the
error just to eliminate the ambiguity
between an exception and an error also
further we will discuss the major
differences between them but now let us
go through the term error first
unlike an exception an error poses a
serious potential threat to the program
or sometimes it is even capable enough
to collapse an entire software
so basically an error is occurred due to
syntax error or some logical error while
coding
so we have a sound understanding of an
exception and an error now let us move
further and learn the differences
between the both
error versus exception
so some of the major differences between
an error and an exception are
an error is classified under unchecked
type whereas on the other hand an
exception is classified under both
checked and unchecked
the next difference is if a program
encounters an error then it turns out to
be completely irrecoverable until the
error is resolved whereas in the case of
an exception
if the program encounters an exception
then the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
java.lang.error
on the other hand an exception belongs
to the class java.lang.exception
the fourth difference says that an error
can be encountered only during the
program's run time whereas on the other
hand an exception can be expected both
during the run time as well as the
compile time
finally we will mention an example for
both an error and an exception
we can consider the input and output
error as an example for error and on the
other hand we can consider divide by
zero exception as an example for
exception
so with the differences discussed we
will now move ahead and have a look at
the exception hierarchy in java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really simple
there is one root class called the
throwable
now the throwable class is basically
inherited from object which comes from
the superior route called java.lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception
further an error is inherited by
different types of errors for example
jvm or java virtual machine error memory
error
and also in some cases some of the
errors are caused by the incompatibility
of the ide or the framework which are
you are using
next up is the exception
now the exception is inherited by few
more exceptions which are mentioned as
below the exceptions can be input output
exception sql exception class not found
exception runtime exception and many
more
further the runtime exception is
inherited by some more
which are the automatic exception
number format exception etc
now that we have a good understanding of
the exception hierarchy let us move
ahead and check the differences between
checked and unchecked exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions
these are really simple exceptions and
can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the checked
exception
it is not serious and is completely
ignorable
followed by the checked exceptions we
have the unchecked exceptions
on the other hand the unchecked
exceptions are defined as an exception
that pops up during the run time is
called as the unchecked exception
it is considered as serious and is
caused by logical errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular example is based on
checked exceptions
so basically we have a text document
called data.txt
in the location documents username users
c drive
so this particular data file has five
lines so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input output
and again the same exception
and here
file not sound exception
so these exceptions are errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from c drive
which is data.txt
so this particular data.txt has five
lines of text so what we are going to do
here is try to type in a for loop and
try to read the first three lines of
this particular document so basically
when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not sound exception input
output exception and another input
output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if we run this program
then we can find our lines
so the lines in the data.txt file were
hello welcome to simply learn we are an
e-learning company our certification is
recognized by major mnc's end role and
upskill
so this particular example was for
checked exceptions
now
we will also go through an example for
unchecked exceptions to learn it in a
much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have 10 elements which are 1 2 3 4 five
six seven eight nine and ten
so what we're going to do is we're going
to access the 11th element of the array
which is not really present so this
should throw an exception
array index out of bound exception is
one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move ahead into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have five major
keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows
so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception block
in a program when you specifically type
the exception that you might expect to
face in your program then you describe
it using the keyword try
followed by that the solution for that
exception will be defined in the catch
block so the catch block is used to
specify the solution
finally the finally is a keyword which
has the executable code which is
completely mandatory for a program to
execute
followed by finally we have the throw
keyword the throw keyword basically
throws the exception when it is found
during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect in your program
sometimes you might
try to type in your user defined
exception or sometimes you might type in
the exception that is
default in its way
or in other words it might be system
defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in java
let us move further and solve some of
the most frequently faced exceptions in
java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in
java so the first one is the array index
out of bound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
address maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown
so to understand this particular
exception let us go through a practical
example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer data type so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is
0 1 2 3 and 4. now we are going to
provide the address of the required
element so during that process we are
going to specify
one location which is more than the
maximum location of the array so here
the maximum location of the array is 4
and if we try to provide the location 5
then this program should throw us an
exception
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so as you can see we have our array here
now
the program is requesting us to provide
the address of the element required so
what if we provide file
so now it should throw an exception
so this exception is the array index out
of bound exception
now let us try to run this program again
and specify the proper address
so for this time let's provide 4 and see
if we get the output
so as you can see at the address
location we have the element 50 as we
have defined here
now our program is running perfectly all
right
now let's move ahead into the next type
of exception
which is none other than our
null pointer exception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown
so might be a little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical example
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a string called sdr which stores
a text called simplylink
followed by that we have another string
type which stores a null value which is
abc as you can see abc is equals to null
now here we are going to access the
value of abc so here the string abc has
a null value and we are trying to access
it so this particular code segment
should throw an exception called null
pointer exception
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the null pointer
exception so whenever in java if you try
to access the null values then the null
pointer exception is thrown
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception
which is the number format
if you try to store a value with wrong
formatting then this particular
exception is thrown
now to understand this in a much better
way let us try to execute a sample
program
so here on the screen we have a sample
program
where we are trying to cast a string
into integer so this kind of operation
should throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception
followed by this we have another most
commonly faced exception which is the
arithmetic expression
if you try to divide a number by 0 this
particular exception is wrong now let us
go through a practical example
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers and one is equals to
zero and n2 is equals to hundred
so here what we are trying to do is we
are going to divide the number 100 by 0
which is practically not possible so
when we try to execute this particular
program then we should be getting an
exception that says you cannot divide a
number by zero
so there you have your personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
zero try a different number
so this is how the automatic exceptions
work
so with this we have come to our last
topic
which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in java
so the first one is use exceptions
conservatively
so exceptions have proven that they can
be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessarily
so it's better to use boolean values to
indicate successful implementation of
smaller operations for example if you
specify a particular operation and it
successfully gets executed then you can
just notify the user by specifying a
boolean value which can be one or in the
case of failure you can just specify the
number zero
next after that we have the customized
exceptions
it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design time rather than planning them on
the go so in other words we can consider
this as if you're planning to design a
software then in that particular stage
itself you must also evaluate the kind
of exceptions you might face on the
process of designing
so tomorrow if you completely design a
software and suddenly an exception is
popped in your head then designing or
including that particular exception in
your finished software might be
difficult
so it's better you start planning your
exceptions
followed by that we have exception
logging
keep track of the exceptions and this
process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has popped up
followed by that we have early through
and early fail an exception should be
thrown as early as possible and should
be resolved in the same pace
and then we have the closing resources
since exceptions halt the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are shut so as to save
the resources
what is jdbc
jdbc is a tool or an application
programming interface that establishes a
connection between standard database and
java application that intends to use
that database
need for jdbc
establishing database connectivity to
execute mysql or sql queries and ddl dml
commands
view and modify data records
and one of the most important things to
look at when we're talking about a jdbc
and probably uh the most confusing part
where the devil's in the details
is data types in a jdbc
so we start looking at the data types
and you're setting up your data you have
your sql which is your var character and
your java equivalent
java.language.string
and you have your bit in sql in java
it's boolean in sql it's numeric
big
java.math.bigdecimal
integer int
real float float float
so there's no real difference in job
between a real number and a float number
your double is double your binary is a
byte
data java sql date so your date and
java.sql date
and there's also your sql timestamp
java.sql timestamp
array java.sql array reference java
sql.reference structure java.sql
structure
character java.language.string
big integer long in java
variable binary it's a byte
a clob
and that's character large object and
then equivalent is java.sql.clob
and then you have your blob in sql
which is a collection of binary data
stored as a single entity and the
equivalent in java is going to be your
java sql.blob
now if you're doing a lot of programming
i would suggest having a cheat sheet
there and then once you're up and
running you'll start to remember most of
these just because out of use
with the jdbc architecture
we're looking at the application then it
goes into the jdbc api so you have your
application your writing your java
database connector api
then that has a manager underneath of it
and then you have your java database
connection drivers and the drivers are
the ones that are transferring that
whether it's an sql server mysql server
the oracle database or different sources
that use a jdbc connection
jdbc environment setup
so when we talk about the environment
setup we have java and your
environmental setup underneath of that
in setting up a java environment you
have to download the latest jdk set java
to home and set your java path so if
you're just using eclipse for the first
time or whatever ide you're using to
program you want to make sure you have
that all set up and you have the current
jdk in there the java development
package
and then with mysql
setting up mysql environment download
the latest mysql workbench extract the
file run the setup file and that'll get
you set up with your own mysql on your
computer
and mysql registers with your operating
system so it's kind of like a global
variable when you start accessing it and
it's designed that way because normally
when you're using an sql or mysql
database it's installed on a server
so it makes sense that you want it
registered with the operating system so
it's accessed globally
steps to connect your jdbc
step one import your packages this
procedure is followed to make sure that
the relevant packages are readily
available for the api
step 2 load and register your driver the
imported driver drivers needed to be
loaded and registered for establishing a
connection between application and
database and if remember in this case
we're doing the mysql so we make sure
our mysql driver is installed
and step 3 connecting database after the
first two steps the next stage is to
connect the database this can be done by
a git connection
step 4 writing a query
so now we're actually starting it into
your scripting here we write in the sql
command or query that we need to execute
if you're not familiar with sql it's
good to have an sql cheat sheet set
setup
once you start understanding how it's
put together you'll find that it goes
really quick and it's pretty fast to
learn but it is its own query language
and you do need to learn a number of the
main settings in poll language so you
know what you're doing
step five executing query now the query
from the api is executed using execute
query
and we'll actually load that up just as
a string variable when we look at that
you'll see how that fits together
step six processing result after step
five the system basically does two
things it processes an output and
retrieves the values from your query
and then step 7 closing statement the
result set and statement needs to be
closed explicitly
and you'll find there's two closing
statements there is your result set
which is still pulling from the database
and then step eight
which is we need to actually close
closing connection so the last stage is
to disconnect ourselves or the api from
the database so we no longer have that
open connection using resources
so we're going to jump into our java
database
connection example
and we're going to do that with what we
call the university database
let's start with a basic overview of
mysql and you can go to dev.mysql.com
and you'll see here we can look up more
information they have the download of
the newest version
this is
a full sql database package
and some of these you can actually go in
there and if you're doing a database
management they can spread across up to
usually don't want to go more than five
servers but
it is designed to go up to five servers
kind of set up with terabytes of data in
there for a developer on the programming
side we usually want to install
something like mysql
locally so on my setup it has no network
connections
it doesn't auto start on the boot up of
the computer
and i have it locked down that way if i
use some kind of simple password or
something like that for one of my demos
it doesn't go anywhere no one can access
it
now another option to mysql is also the
sqlite
and you can go to the sqlite.org
read more about it and download it
it has a couple limitations that you're
not going to see in your regular your
full scale mysql or oracle or sql
but most of it will transfer over and so
for a small project you can actually use
it as a backend for storing your data
you can also
integrate it or upgrade it into my sql
because most of the sql commands are the
same
and when you go into
the mysql which is a significant
download versus sql lite
you can certainly go down to downloads
and then there's also
the connectors so devmysql.com
download slash connector slash j
and i bring this up because it depends
on how you set up eclipse
for your interface and your ide and it
depends on what you need and how exactly
on your setup as far as the connectors
we'll look at that a little bit more
closer
in the mysql it isn't oracle-based so
you'll have to set up an account if you
don't have one you have to log in it's
all free as long as you're not doing
like the enterprise with all the support
and help on it you don't have to pay for
it it's an open source
now once you've installed uh mysql and
if you do sqlite you're not going to
have these interfaces it'll all be done
from java code
but once you've installed mysql it's
going to add in a terminal window and
then also
the workbench which is just a nice gui
interface for mysql server
and we're not going to do anything with
the workbench you can play with it
certainly
because a lot of times you don't have
the workbench installed on your computer
especially if the mysql
is set up on a different server and
you're remote accessing it especially
like if you're in the classroom or
something like that they probably have
sent you your login information so you
can get into the shell quick note though
is if you do your own mysql just note
that i kept this as a local host you can
actually see it down here root local
host
no outward connections and that's just
to protect my computer once you start
opening those you have to be aware of
your passwords and since i'm doing demos
i want to keep my passwords really
simple so that's not the focus of the
programming
i had to log out and relog back in
so once you've gone in there you should
have this a lot of times your interface
might be web based if it's a remote
mysql connection you're working with and
i'll prompt you for your username and
password
in this case mine is on my computer it
automatically has me login as admin so i
have full admin rights
and then we always like to start by at
least i do is show databases
and these are the current databases on
here
they have some different information on
them that is part of the basic setup and
some examples like sakila
and world are both example databases
that automatically load with mysql
for this example we're going to create a
database
and it's going to be university we'll do
capital there university
don't forget our semicolon
and
time you can see how long it took 0.69
seconds and of course if we go show
databases
you'll see now that there is a
university in there
and we want to go ahead and use
university
that means that whatever we do any
commands that we have in here for tables
or whatever are now going to be going
into the university database
so now our database has changed
and let's go ahead and zoom in
let's see here we go set okay
a little bit more so we get a nice big
print so you can see what i'm doing a
little bit better
there we go
all right so we're going to go ahead and
create our table
and this has all been prepared so i
don't have to go through and and redo it
all the time
you'll see here we're going to do
create a table engineering student
and then we have student id is an
integer not null department variable
character 25 long first name
last name pass out year
university rank primary key
in creating this uh note a couple things
first we created a table engineering
students and we've gone ahead and
created the fields as part of the create
setup here
and the things i want you to note is
that we have our integer so our student
id is an integer our department is a
variable character and is 25 long
and the reason i say that that is really
important is when we flip back on over
here if you remember from our
there we go
if you remember from our data types
here's our variable character and in
java language that's a string
a string
doesn't say hey it's only 25 long and so
you've got to be a little careful when
you're pushing and pulling this data
especially when you're writing the data
from java into the sql that you check
for that length of that string
and then the integer is of course an
integer and of course your other data
types you can see how they follow suit
but with variable character be very
aware of that that that is a designated
25 characters long
and we're going to go ahead and insert
some data in here
here we go we'll go ahead and insert
into
engineering students values
and this is going to be the student id
and it's also the primary key so keep in
mind that that is a
unique value in there and then we have
cse computer science engineering koran
ackeria 2018 1272. so there's our
pass out year 2018
and ranked
i guess number 1272
not sure where the um oh it's a
university ranking there we go
and then we have some prepared data
which i just went ahead and pasted in so
we have a whole bunch of individuals in
our database now
and we'll i mean it's the same line over
and over again insert into engineering
students values and then you have your
list of values
and we can see that by doing a simple uh
select
uh
we'll do what's the star so it's going
to select everything one of our hot
characters
if you're not familiar with um sql get a
setup on there and look it over
and you can also
download a cheat sheet from somewhere
with all the different commands in there
i myself do a lot of
consulting and so i'm always jumping
around from one platform to another
if you're doing that kind of work it's
more important to understand the
limitations and the advantages of
different systems and then you have your
cheat sheets for putting together stuff
really quickly when you need it
and you can see here the data we just
put in there there's our student ids
department first name last name
pass out year
and university
rank we'll go ahead and do one query in
here real quick we're gonna we already
did one query we're gonna do two queries
uh we did select star from engineering
and then we're gonna go ahead and select
student id department first name last
name so you can actually choose what you
select instead of doing the asterisks
where student id equals 10202
and when we go ahead and execute that in
here
oops
there we go uh you'll see that it
returns the one individual with that
student id here
uh so let's take this back into our
eclipse because we're still doing the
setup so you have your mysql server set
up or you did sql lite with a little bit
different setup going on there
and let's flip on over and see what's
going on with eclipse
so in eclipse we're going to go in new
we'll start a new project
and we'll call this jdbc
it's our jdbc project whoops
select a wizard
i forgot where i was going on there it's
a java wizard we're looking for this
project java project
there we go and we're going to call this
there now we're in the right spot uh jd
bc package that way everything will be
bundled in there in the same package and
finish it
create all right so you can see right
here we have our new jdbc package we're
working with
now at this point there's a lot going on
as far as your options
if you set this up for doing database
management which i did not and i'm going
to show you the two different ways you
can go under
windows and under preferences
and in this list you'll see
database management and then you can
just go in there and set it up this way
and it'll pull in that information for
your sql connections
now if you did not and you downloaded
the mysql
it does have an option to download the
java connex which would put it into
wherever you installed that at which is
default under your c drive program files
now on mine
i didn't i downloaded the connection
separately
and there's two different ways we can go
under project and under the build
project
give that a moment to come up
oops i mean properties there we go the
project properties and the java build
path
this same window can be accessed by
right-clicking on your
package we're working on and then we can
go down to properties and you'll see the
same window opens up
and we're going to go under java build
path
and we're going under libraries so these
are libraries we want to include in our
setup
and then i click on our module path and
at this point you'll see add external
jars here
now again if you haven't already preset
up any clips you can just add jars and
it will be in the jar library
so there's different possibilities there
but i did a download so i'm going to go
add external jars
and i happen to keep mine on my d volume
under my sql
and you'll see my sql
connector java and this is
mysql 8.0
and i just go in here
oops there we go i just go ahead and
open this up and you'll see right here
it has my connector java
once i set that in it's now added those
packages and there's hundreds of actual
subfiles in there and it's all set to go
and i can apply and close this window
and now i'm ready to go ahead and start
writing my script and start building a
program in here
and let's go ahead and go under source
new i'm going to put in a new class in
here and we'll just go call it jdbc
same as the package i'm going to finish
that
and we're set up with a new class in
here
and once we've got this set the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and import
all of our java setup in here so we have
the java connection and now we want to
go ahead and import it
and when we look at this
we can see we have our
connection and remember two of these
have to be closed explicitly and that's
your connection
when you create the statement you have
your driver manager
so when it goes in there that's a piece
that connects to actually does the
connection to the
database the drivers that convert
everything in the code in there so you
have your connection to the database you
have the code that converts it
you have your result so you're going to
get a result off of your query
then you have your exception so if you
have an error throws or something like
that that's where that's going and of
course the actual statement that you're
going to send to the sql server
and of course we want our java to be
able to actually run so we'll put our
main in there public static void main
and it's going to throw the sql
exception
so you'll see right here that's what
we're working with and there's our
javasql sql exception on there
so the first thing we're going to need
on our setup let's put that in here is
going to be our connection information
we need to know the username i'm just
going to call it string you name equals
in this case i created a user
richard underscore simply learn
and then i created a password my
password remember this is a local host
so you probably don't want to have a
simple password like that but mike this
whole database is locked down on just
this computer there's no outside network
access or anything like that to get in
here
and then of course this is a separate
user so it's not even my admin or root
user and then we go ahead and put a
query right here in this case we'll
start with our most basic query if you
remember we already did that on our at
the very beginning select star from
engineering students
and we're going to use that query in our
code to start off with
and then another really common thing
when you're setting this up
is that we also want to test it and see
hey did we import our package correctly
is it set up correctly
so remember we came in and we
imported our mysql connector jar file
in the code we would just want to make
sure it's it's working correctly and
that's what this is it says try class
for name and then it has our
com.mysql.cj.jdbcdriver
saying hey do we have the driver for
this that's all that's doing
and if not then it's going to print an
error so we can find out why it doesn't
have that driver
and then next we want to actually start
getting into our actual code and in here
we're going to do a try because whenever
you do any kind of major connection you
want to make sure
that
you're looking for your errors you're
not going to miss on anything and we're
going to do a catch
and so we're looking for any kind of sql
exception error
and for this demo we'll just do
you know print it out so um oops wrong
spot
goes into the catch section there we go
uh so we'll print it out over down here
as far as the error on there and it's an
xql exception so still looking for the
code which we haven't put in here yet
and this is really where the the magic
really starts to happen because we have
our
connection
and
there we go
and you'll see that the connection is
that's all this is right here here's our
connection up here
and
we pop it down here we have a connection
we'll just call it con
one end so keep it uniform
there we go and this is going to go to
the driver uh so in other words right
here we're going to need a
the driver manager and that's where we
imported here and it says get connection
because that's part of the driver
manager
and we have um our url
let's see and we of course forgot to put
the url in up above so let's go ahead
and go back there and put that in
and the url comes out as a jdbc mysql
that is registered with my computer so
my computer has when it's running the
mysql
this is the
host
in this case we call it university
that's where this comes from
and that's all part of your mysql setup
if you're working with a remote database
you'd want to get this information from
the remote whoever set the database up
so that you have this particular line of
where to call
and so we go back down here we have our
connection it's all set up on here the
next thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead
and
create our statement
and this initializes it so we have a
statement called statement
but this statement is going to be based
on our
driver manager which is then connected
to the connection so these are all
connected to each other and this
generates the format it needs
for when we actually send our inquiry
remember here's our query right here so
we're going to send select star from
engineering students for right now
we haven't put that part in we're just
creating the class or initiating the
instance so that we can do that
and then once we've initiated the
instance here let's go down here
we need to go ahead and generate a
result and so we have our result set
again that comes up here from what we
brought in
we're storing the data coming in or
storing the pipeline to bring it in
we're just going to call that result and
then we have this is generated from our
statement here's our statement so this
is all like linked together here's our
execute query which is part of the
statement and here's the actual query
which is coming that we put together the
select star from engineering students
and then finally we want to actually do
something with our information
so we'll do is we'll just loop through
it while
and here's our result
set that we just generated so wall
result dot
next
and this just generates a boolean so it
says hey there's still another result
coming in so we need to go ahead and get
that next result
then we'll go ahead and create a and
we'll take that string university data
and then
we're going to loop through the
different results
there we go
integer and then
here we go university
data
and we want to tag on the end of it
result.getstring i
so what's going on here there we just
did a bunch of things uh we are going
through each row
result.next each row of data that comes
off of the database until this returns
no there's no next
result coming in there
and then we come in there we look at the
result the one we're looking at is the
current one so it goes through i forget
how many we put in there about 20 it was
you know row twenty zero row one row two
row three row four
and then on each of these rows
we have a string it's an array of
strings
and we're going to get that string and
it returns i so this is get string of
column i
uh so we have row and column
and really important it is programming
to really understand rows and columns
because that's so central to most of the
data processing going on
and then finally we want to go ahead and
see our results so let's print them out
we'll put in our nice print statement
system out print line university data so
this is going to print each row as it
goes through it and then i'll reset the
row again to an empty string and then
i'll add each of the columns to that row
for my result and then we'll print the
next row out
and now that we have a complete code
let's go ahead and go up here hit the
run button
it's going to compile it runs it out and
we can see down here
let me just get my double mouse we can
get a better view
uh here's our different uh your id comes
up
with their i forget what the actual
setup was but the cse the name the date
the ranking
all that prints out one row at a time
and that's what we're doing here of
course if you're processing the data
differently you might be loading this
into a
user interface this might be generating
other information you may be doing
statistics with it
but you can see
how it's set up in here as far as
pulling the data into the java format
and then running it from there
just so we can get a quick glimpse of
where this goes let's go back up here
and we're going to flip back and forth
between a couple different screens so
let me do that
uh and here if you remember we did
select star from engineering students
and there's the same thing up here that
we got down here this is our my sequel
server interface and this is the
interface we built in java
and from here we also did this
particular selection select student id
department first name last name pass out
year university rank from engineering
students where student id is
and we got the single row on here
and uh this is kind of interesting
because i switched something in the code
here where this could cause a problem it
won't on this one
let me go ahead and paste this in here
and we'll run and compile this one
and you see it comes out with the single
user
so the danger of this particular code
is that i went ahead and hard coded in a
loop for i equals one to six
and so this one we pulled it just
happened to be that we did selected six
different columns in here so you got to
be a little careful when you're coding
in here what are you polling and where
is it going uh you can see if i take out
oh let's do
we'll just remove the student id
and we're going to run that without the
student id
we compile it there we go and it gives
us a bunch of errors because it doesn't
see the we're short a column down here
so when it gets down to this code down
here
under the while statement
and it goes hey where's number six well
there's no number six and so we get a
lot of errors on that
and you can see where our queries uh let
me just go back up here and paste
another query in
there we go
and we'll run this one and we're looking
at is uh we're going to go ahead and do
the same columns
and
we'll just leave this as a star to make
it easy so we're going to select all
columns
from engineering students where the pass
out year is 2018.
just do a copy of that one
and we'll run that
it recompiles
and you can see here's all the 2018
on here if you look at the dates so
they're all 2018
and that's the same as our
query directly into the sql server if i
do the same thing on here
you'll see they're exactly the same
and just because we're having fun let's
flip this back over here and we'll do
one more
sql server
and let's do in this one
let's just take this whole thing out
here
and in this one we're going to pull in
all the departments but i want the
minimal university ranking as the
highest from engineering students that
way we can get an order of the rankings
on here
and we'll go ahead and run this
and there we go there's our minimal one
so this one hit the lowest ranking on
there or closest to number one
and we can do that in here and get the
same result uh there's karen karen is
awesome uh ranking number 96
and you saw there's other people that
are ranked way below koran so that's
this guy must be super smart
so that concludes our jdbc example
university database where we took a
quick look at mysql server
or you can do sqlite and some basic
queries you can put in there and how
that works
what exactly is a servlet
now imagine you are searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it
this question from you to the internet
is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud or in technical terms your browser
sends your request to the respective
server responsible for storing for that
particular information and helps you
with it when requested now the server
gets triggered with your request and in
written it helps you back with the
information you have requested for
this answer from the server is called
the response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server for this process to
happen so smoothly and effectively we
need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server we find the component
responsible for such an effective job it
is called the servlet container that
holds java based web application and a
set of individual components called as
servlets
now we are close to our answer so this
particular java based component takes
care of web requests and response to sum
it up with the form of a definition
we can define it as follows
a servlet is a java program that runs on
the java enabled web server or
application server they are used to
handle the request obtained from the web
server process the request produce the
response and then send a response back
to the web server now hoping that it was
a clear explanation can we move ahead
with the next topic
so the next topic we have is
so how does the servlet work in reality
or more practically or in depth what's
the life cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life to
get our work done so the stages are in
it service
and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created and not for all the requests
afterwards so it is used for the
one-time initializations just as with
the init method of applets the servlet
is normally created when a user first
invokes a url corresponding to the
servlet but you can also specify the
servlet is loaded when the server first
started when a user invokes a servlet a
single instance of each servlet gets
created
with each user request resulting in a
new thread that is handed over to the do
get or do post as appropriate
the init method simply creates or load
some data that will be used throughout
the lifecycle of a servlet followed by
the init method we have the service
method
so what is service method
surface method is the main method to
perform the actual task the servlet
container that is the web server calls
the service method to handle request
from the client or the browser and to
write the formatted response back to the
client each time the server receives a
request from the servlet the server
spawns a new thread and calls service
the service method checks the http
service type and accordingly performs
the crud operations which are the get
post
put delete etc and calls do get do post
do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate
the service method is called by the
container and service method invokes do
get do post do put and do delete etc
methods as appropriate so you have
nothing to do with service method but
you overwrite either with do get do post
and other types depending on what type
of request you receive from the client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete and
do put methods
so first we will discuss about do get
method so what exactly does a doget
method do a get request results from a
normal request from a url or an html
form that has no method specified and it
should be hardly by do get method
followed by do get we have
do post
a do post request results from html form
that specifies list post as the method
and it should be handled by do post
method similar to to get and do post the
do put and do delete options are usually
used to update and delete the data
when asked by the client
so to sum up these do get do post do put
do delete we can consider them as crud
operations so do get basically gets the
information what you're looking for do
post method usually post the information
or provides you with the response from
the server and followed by that we have
the do put which is usually used to
update the data which is present on your
server and finally delete which is used
to delete an existing data on your
server so these can be considered as
crud operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method
the destroy method is called only once
at the end of the lifecycle of a servlet
this method gives your servlet a chance
to close database connections halt
background threads right cookie list or
hit counts to the disc and performs
other such cleanup activities so with
this we finish up the life cycle of a
servlet now we shall understand its
architecture
basically the architecture of a servlet
can be understood by reverse engineering
the life cycle of a servlet so this is
how the servlet execution takes place
when a client or a browser makes a
request to the web browser so the
servlet architecture includes the
following first one servlet interface
to write a servlet we need to implement
the servlet interface servlet interface
can be implemented directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or http servlet class
followed by that the next part is
request handling methods as we have
discussed before there are mainly three
methods defined in servlet interface
which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods the first time a servlet
is invoked the init method is called it
is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet so we can put all
your initialization code here the
service method is used for handling the
client request as the client request
reaches the container it creates a
thread of servlet object and request and
response object are also created
these request and response objects are
then passed as parameter to the service
method which then processes the client
request the service method in turn calls
the do get do post methods if the user
has extended the class from http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this we have finished the
architecture of servlet moving further
we shall quickly discuss the features of
servlets and then enter into the
practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets the first feature is java
servlets are portable in nature as i
have mentioned above the servlets use
java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language the same holds true
for servlets for example you can create
a servlet on windows operating system
that uses glassfish as a web server and
then later run it on any operating
system like unix linux and apache tomcat
web server this feature makes servlet
portable and this is the main advantage
of servlet over cgi we shall discuss all
the differences of cgi versus servlet in
the next section for now we will discuss
the features
followed by the first feature we will
now enter into the second feature which
says java servlets are efficient and
scalable once a server is deployed and
loaded onto a web server it can
instantly start fulfilling the request
of the clients
the web server invokes servlet using
lightweight thread so multiple client
requests can be fulfilled by servlet at
the same time using the multi-threading
feature of java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request the servlet is truly efficient
and scalable the next and the final
feature of java servlets is they are
robust and highly secure by inheriting
the top features of java such as garbage
collector exception handling java
security manager etc the servlet is less
prone to memory management issues and
memory leaks
this makes the development of web
applications and servlets secure and
less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets now
let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode the first one was to set
up the environment for java servlets and
the second one was to execute a basic
program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program so we
have these prerequisites where we have
to set up java home
and java path followed by that we need
to set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path so
catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server home and path
now we will set up these things by using
the environment variables now i'm using
a windows operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
variables
and inside this you can see that i have
already set up the environment variables
for catalina home java home and jre home
so now let us just select java home and
edit it so that we can see how did i set
it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home and inside the
variable value i have a location so this
location is nothing but the java jdk
location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home and the variable value is the
location of gre folder in my local
system so i have my jre folder in my
local system at c drive program files
java jre and similarly the catalina home
which is inside my program files apache
software foundation and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables so inside system
variables you can see
the path just edited so then you can see
the path variable set for java
jre and tomcat
now just select ok
okay and finally another okay
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them so in case
if you have doubts about the tomcat
version to download then i'll help you
with that just open google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site and since i'm using a
windows operating system i'll be
selecting the 32-bit or 64-bit windows
service installer version
and after this gets downloaded you need
to set up the home and path variables
for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to create
a servlet program which are creating a
dynamic web project create a servlet add
servlet api jar file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new and inside that you
have
the option of other just select other
and inside that you'll be finding
web
so select web and inside that you need
to select the dynamic web project and
select next
so you just need to name to your dynamic
web project so i'll be
naming a server
then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you for opening this particular in java
ee perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see
server folder here which has already set
up everything you need
now what you need to do is set up a new
servlet so right click this
and select new
and inside that you can see the option
of servlet just select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up the class name
for now let's just type in hello and go
to next
now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select do get
method
now let's just finish it
and there you go your servlet has been
ready so this is the basic template
created by eclipse for you now next we
need to add in the build path so for
that you need to right click the server
and then
select build path
and here configure build path
from here you can add the external
library select the external libraries
option
and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all and open
and that's how you add all the required
libraries of tomcat server now apply and
close
now the last step is to execute the
project now just to save time i have
already typed in the program
which is over here
now let's try to execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world
now the server i have choose this tomcat
server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully hello welcome to
simply learn
now we'll move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
so let's include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application and
finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information so
these were the advantages of using
servlets in java moving ahead we will
discuss the disadvantages of using
servlets so following are the
disadvantages of using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated so let's often slow
down the application business logic of
servlet is difficult to understand we
need a jre which is the java runtime
environment on the server to run our
servlets and finally the data
connectivity is a little complicated
so these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets and java moving ahead we
will understand cgi
why are we learning cgi because even cgi
is similar to servlets and it also does
the web interactive job similar to
servlets so thought you should know
about some basics of it so let's
understand its definition and
architecture real quick so the cgi or
common gateway interface is a standard
for writing programs that can interact
through a web server with a client
running on web browser
these programs allow a web developer to
deliver dynamic information usually in
the form of an html via the browser a
cgi program can be written in any
language including java that can be
executed by your web server cgi programs
are commonly used to add search engines
guest book applications database query
engines interactive user forms and other
interactive applications to websites in
very basic terms a cgi program must
interpret the information sent to it
process the information in the same way
and generate response that will be sent
back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through environment
variables so with this we will move
ahead into the architecture of common
gateway interface
so you can see the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to servlet normally the request
is sent in the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells and it
will be processed by the cgi shells
based on the program provided and the
response is sent to the user now moving
ahead we shall understand the
differences between the common gateway
interfaces and
the servlet so the first difference is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes written in native
operating system while on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low compared to
servlets on the other hand servlets are
having high performance compared to
cgi's
the third difference is
for a common gateway interface it is
hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely platform
independent
followed by that the common gateway
interface scripts are directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into bytecode because the
servlets are executed using the java
virtual machine and in java virtual
machine whatever the code you transfer
it will be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable and on the other hand we have
the java servlets to be completely
portable so these were the major
differences between the common gateway
interface and java servlets now let us
understand the java servlets requests
and responses so first we will deal with
the request phase in request we have
various types the first one is being the
http request the http object is used to
represent the http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible through the http
request followed by the http request we
have the request parameter the request
parameters are the parameters that are
sent from the web browser along with the
request the request parameters are
typically sent as a part of the url or
as a part of the body of an http request
followed by the request parameter we
have the request header the request
headers are the name value pairs sent by
the browser along with the http request
the request headers contain the
information about the web browser
software being used what type of files
that the web browser can receive etc
followed by the request header we have
the input stream if the browser sends an
http post request request parameters and
other potential data is sent to the
server in the http request body it
doesn't have the request parameters that
is sent in http request body it could be
pretty much as the data like file or
soap request
the next one is a request session the
session object can hold information
about a given user between the requests
so if we have set an object into the
session object during one request it
will be available for you to read during
any subsequent request within the same
session time scope followed by the
request session we have the servlet
context the servlet context contains the
metadata related to the application
followed by sublet context
we will enter the response phase in the
response phase we will deal with the
first one which is the http response the
http response object is used to
represent the http response to your
request a web application sends back a
response page to the user as a response
to the http request from the browser
sent to your web application
followed by the http response we have
the right html to initiate the process
of sending the html back to the browser
you need to retrieve the print writer
from the http response object
this can be done using the right html
followed by the right html we have the
response header similar to http request
the http response includes headers as
well these are responsible for all the
data written in the response followed by
response header we have content type the
content type header is responsible to
tell the browser about the type of
content you are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you about the
number of bytes your servlet is sending
you in return followed by content length
we have redirection redirecting will
help you to redirect yourself to the
different web page from the current one
so these were the http requests and
responses in java servlets now we will
enter the next part where we will deal
with the session tracking and cookies so
first we will understand session
tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval session
tracking is a way to maintain state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as session management and servlets
http protocol is stateless so we need to
maintain state using session tracking
techniques each time the user requests
to the server the server reads the
request as a new request so we need to
maintain the state of a user to
recognize a particular user you can
understand this in a better way by
looking at the picture shown on the
presentation each time you send a
request you will be receiving a response
from the server as well as this
particular request will be recorded as a
state in order to recognize you as a
particular user now after session
tracking we will enter into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between multiple
client requests a cookie has a name a
single value and optional attributes
such as comment path and domain
qualifiers a maximum age and a version
number by default each request is
considered as a new request in cookie
technique we add a cookie with response
from the servlet so cookie is stored in
cache of a browser after that if the
request is sent by the user the cookie
is added with a request by default thus
we recognize the user as an old user
there are two types of cookies they are
non-persistent cookie and persistent
cooking let's understand non-persistent
cookie first a non-persistent cookie is
valid for a single session only it is
removed each time when the user closes
the browser now let us understand the
persistent cookie the persistent cookie
is valid for multiple sessions it is not
removed each time when the user closes
the browser it is only removed when the
user logs out or signs out from the
browser before we begin with what
exactly is a java api we will understand
what java is
so basically java consists of two major
components
that are java runtime environment and
java development kit
so when we get into java's api we might
want to dig a little deep into java's
development kit
so jdk consists of three more major
components that are the java's compiler
java virtual machine and apis now we
will learn each one of them in a bit
more detailed way so at first we have
the java's compiler
so java compiler can be defined as a
software program that is designed to
convert the high level that is the user
return or user readable code into the
computer readable code that is the
machine level or byte code so this
particular byte code will be transferred
to the next state where we find the jvm
so what is jvm so jvm is an abbreviation
for java's virtual machine so java's
virtual machine is responsible for
processing all the byte codes and
providing an output to the user
next we find our topic for today's
discussion that is the java api
so just like java's virtual machine and
compiler java's apis are the integral
software packages that come with the jdk
the primary intention of api is to
establish communications between
different applications
so on my screen you can see a pictorial
representation of java api's
architecture so at first we have the
java's program on the topmost layer so
this particular segment will be having
the user return program and user
language
followed by that we have the interpreter
javas api and the java's virtual machine
which are responsible for reading and
compiling the java's program
so at the last final level we have the
application hardware which is
responsible for interacting to the
java's program so this is how the java
aps architecture looks like now followed
by this let's dive into the next topic
so in the next topic we find the types
of developers using various types of
apis for different jobs
so at first we have the open developers
next we have the internal developers and
at last we have the partner developers
don't worry we will understand each of
these developers in a bit more detail
and along with some examples for a
better understanding
so at first we have the open developers
so open developers are used by top-end
companies so leading companies provide
access to their apis as open source
through authentication via a unique
secret key to keep track and ensure the
legal usage
so basically what happens here is there
might be some big companies like social
media companies or some more other
companies which provide the api they use
for their applications as open source to
the developers so these open developers
get access to their apis through getting
authentication
so they'll be creating a profile they'll
be providing the research details of
their application like what are they
using that particular api for and other
reasons to use those apis then they get
the unique secret key from the owner of
that api
and that's done just to keep track that
the api provided is not misused
so the open developers majorly include
the b2bc teams and some of the major
companies that provide the apis for open
developers are twitter and telnex so one
best example is the twitter where the
twitter provides twitter api for the
twitter developer accounts for using
that for any kind of developing things
or some data science applications and
much more
so followed by the open developers next
we have
the internal developers
so you can consider internal developers
as an organization
so the internal developers belong to a
specific organization and work in a
close environment these apis run with a
high security that can establish
communication between the application
and the application hardware
so only the internal developers that is
the developers belonging to that
particular organization have the access
to that particular api
so this particular type of apis
run on a high security level
so internal developers majorly include
b2c teams b2b teams a to a teams and b2e
teams
so some of the major companies that
provide the internal apis are instagram
google mail and google cloud virtual
machines
next we have the partner apis
so the partner developers are similar or
like internal developers but the only
difference is there is a collaboration
between two or multiple companies for
example consider yourself to be linked
with a different company and you both
wanted to create an application so only
you both can have access to that
particular api that you're using to
create your application
so partner developers majorly use the
b2c teams and the major companies
providing the partner apis are microsoft
and fenextra
so with this we finished the first topic
that was what is api and who exactly
uses it and for what purposes now we
dive into the next segment where we
learn the need for java apis
so why exactly we need java apis
now java apis are used for multiple
reasons but the three most important
reasons for which we use java apis are
to streamline the operations improvise
the businesses and finally create some
powerful applications we will discuss
each one of them in a bit more detail
so the first one is to streamline
operating procedures we have multiple
social media applications like twitter
facebook whatsapp etc followed by that
we have multiple delivery applications
such as amazon flipkart then we have the
fnb such as zomantoswiggy etc so all
these applications are running smooth
and hassle-free because of the
significant improvement in the
implementation of java apis by using
java's apis users are provided with
multiple options on the screen so this
kind of approach makes the functionality
very simple and easy to use
followed by this the next important
requirement is
to improvise the business
introducing apis to the public leads
many companies to release private data
to generate new ideas fixing existing
bugs and receive new ways to improvise
operations the twitter developer account
is an example for api that gives
programmers private api keys to access
twitter data and develop applications
followed by that we have the third one
which is to create the powerful
applications online banking has changed
the industry forever and apis offer the
customers ability to manage their
finances digitally with complete
simplicity so this is made possible only
by the use of apis
now followed by this we will dive into
the next topic where we understand the
types of java apis
so basically there are four different
types of apis in java
they are public private partner and
composite we will discuss each one of
these apis in a bit more detail
at first we will deal with the public
api
so what are public apis public means
open so public or open apis are java's
apis that come with the jdk
and they do not have any strict
restrictions about how developers use
them
so followed by the public apis we have
the private apis so the private or
internal apis are developed for a
specific organization these particular
apis will be accessible
through the authentication by only the
employees belonging to that particular
organization
so followed by private apis we have the
partner apis
so similar to private apis even partner
apis are having some authentication
process to use so
the only difference is here instead of
one organization we might have two or
multiple organizations and the employees
belonging to that particular group of
organizations will be able to access the
apis and implement them or use them
followed by partner apis we have the
last one which is the composite api
composite apis are microservices and
developers build them by combining
several service apis
now that we have covered the different
types of apis let us now discuss the
categorization of java apis based on the
services that different varieties of
apis in java provide
so data and api services are another way
to categorize java apis other than the
previous type which is the public
private partner and composite apis are
also classified based on their data
manipulation capabilities and the
variety of services they offer so this
type of categorization has four
different types which are the internal
api services external api services crud
operations and user interface services
we will understand each one of them in a
bit more detail at first we will
understand internal api services
internal api services are developed to
offer organizations services specific to
that particular organizations
these services include only complex data
operations and internal processes
followed by internal api we have the
external api
external api are open source apis that
developers integrate into existing
application or website so internal apis
are something similar to private apis
and externals apis are something similar
to
public apis next we have the crud
operations so credit apis provide data
manipulation operations over various
data storage units such as software and
service that is sas and relational
database management systems such as
rdbms using standard data storage unit
connecting tools like database
connectivity that is jdbc etc
next we have the user interface services
user interface service apis are open
source apis that allow developers to
build user interfaces for mobile devices
computers and electronics now let's
examine the rules and protocols that
java apis must follow
so that brings us to api service
protocols
the rules and protocols guide the
different functionalities of java apis
so different apis have different service
protocols let's consider an example for
restful api service protocol as an
example
so for a typical restful api developers
must follow the following rules
for a typical restful api developers
must follow these rules
stateless uniform interface client
server cache layer no worries we will
discuss each one of these protocols in
detail first we will discuss stateless
so what exactly is stateless
so since the restful api follows client
server architecture by default it is
recommended that restful api services to
be stateless all the time
next we have the uniform interface the
entities in a restful api are server and
clients
applications that run on global scale
need uniform client and server interface
through hypertext transfer protocol or
http and uniform resource identifiers
uri will allocate the required resources
next we have the client server
the client server model used in the
restful api should be fault tolerant
both the client and server are expected
to operate independently the change is
made at the client and should not affect
the server and vice versa
next we have the cache including a cache
memory allows the application to record
intermediate responses and run faster in
real time a restful api also includes
the cache memory
and next we have the layer
a restful api is built using layers
layers of api are loosely coupled or
independent from each other each layer
contributes a different level of
hierarchy and also supports
encapsulation
next we will go through some frequently
used apis
so this is the list of most frequently
used apis in real time so we have web
api facebook 4j twitter 4g android api
java advanced imaging java data objects
and you can also see the acronyms for
them in the right column so some of them
have no acronyms and some of them have
acronyms for example we have android api
as google java advanced imaging as jei
data objects as jdo etc so moving into
the next slide we have a few more apis
so we have restful apis java media
frameworks java per system apis java
speech api java 3d java usb for windows
etc and similarly on the right column we
have their acronyms so for java media
frameworks we have jmf for restful apis
we have nothing and java 3d we have j3d
java speech api as js api and few others
so followed by this we will advance into
the next topic where we will discuss
about the advantages of using java's
apis
now using java's apis will help you with
multiple advantages now we will discuss
the most important advantages of using
java's apis
so the first one we have the extensive
sql support apis in java enable a wide
range of sql support services in users
applications through a component-based
interface
next we have applications apis in java
provide effortless access to all of an
application's major software components
and easily deliver services
next we have efficiency
java's apis are highly efficient because
they enable rapid application
development also the data that the
application generates is always
available online
next we have the automation api allows
computers to automatically upload a
download update and delete data
automatically without human interaction
followed by that we have integration
java apis can integrate to any
application and website and provide a
fluidic experience with dynamic data
delivery
followed by that we have scope java's
apis make websites application and
information available to a wide range of
users and audience
followed by that we have customization
java aps enabled developers and
businesses to build applications that
personalize user interface and data and
finally we have the adaptability java
aps are highly flexible and adaptable
because they can easily accept feature
updates and change to frameworks and
operating systems
now let's quickly begin with what
exactly is java enterprise edition
the java ee stands for java enterprise
edition which was earlier known as j2ee
and is currently known as jar kataka ee
the java enterprise edition provides a
platform for developers with enterprise
features such as distributed computing
and web services
now let's move further and understand
why exactly we needed java enterprise
edition we needed java enterprise
edition for four major reasons to have
powerful api support to reduce
development time to reduce application
complexity and finally to improve the
application performance so followed by
the need for java enterprise edition we
will move ahead and understand the java
enterprise specifications so in the java
enterprise specifications we are going
to discuss the four major specifications
used by enterprise developers so the
first one being the enterprise
specification followed by that we have a
web specification then we have web
server specification and finally some
other miscellaneous specifications we
shall discuss each one of them in detail
firstly we will move ahead with
enterprise specification so in
enterprise specification we have the
first one to discuss that is the context
dependency injection
the context dependency injection
provides a container to inject
dependencies as in swing
next we have java enterprise java bean
the enterprise java bean is a set of
lightweight apis that an object
container possesses in order to provide
transactions remote procedure calls and
concurrency control
followed by java bean we have java
persistent apis so the java persistent
api are the specifications of object
relational mapping between relational
database tables and java classes
next we have the java transaction api
it consists of java interfaces and
annotations to establish interaction
between java transaction support offered
by java enterprise edition the api is in
the abstract from low level detail to
the interfaces are also considered as
low level followed by java transaction
api we have the java servlet
the java servlet specifications define
how you can manage http request either
in a synchronous or asynchronous way
so followed by java transaction api
which is one of the enterprise
specifications we will move ahead into
the java web specifications
so the first one in the java web
specification is the java servlet
so this specification defines how you
can manage the http request either in
asynchronous or asynchronous way it is
low level and other specifications
completely depend on it
so followed by java servlet we have the
java web socket
so the java web socket is a computer
communication protocol and this api
provides a set of apis to facilitate web
socket connections
followed by websocket we have the java
server faces
so the java server faces is a service
which helps in building graphical user
interface out of the components so
followed by java server faces we have
the unified expression language the
unified expression language is a simple
language which was designed to
facilitate web application developers so
followed by the web specification now we
will enter the web server specification
out of which we have the first one which
is a restful web service so the java
restful api web service provides
services having representational state
transfer schema
next we have the json processing
java api for json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided in a json format followed by
json processing we have json binding so
the java api for json binding is a set
of specifications that provide for
binding or parsing a json file into java
classes
next we have the xml binding so xml
binding simply allows for binding of xml
into java objects for example soap is an
xml based protocol to access web
services over http this api allows you
to create soap web services so followed
by the web service specifications of
java enterprise edition we finally enter
into the other miscellaneous
specifications of java enterprise
edition
sort of that the first one is the
validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by bean validation api
in java followed by validation we have
the patch applications so the batch
applications provide the means to run
long-running background tasks which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically executed
followed by batch applications we have
java enterprise connector architecture
so the java enterprise edition connector
is a java based technological solution
for connecting java service to
enterprise information system so with
this we will enter into our next step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install java enterprise
edition
so the basic requirements to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system are you should be having the java
virtual machine from the standard six
edition or more followed by that your
local system should be having at least
gb of ram capacity
next your system should be having at
least 250 gb rom space available and
finally you should be having the java
development kit installed into your
local system
now next we will understand how to
install java enterprise edition into
your local system
so in short these are the steps you need
to follow to install java enterprise
edition into your local system first you
need to browse into the oracle official
java site then go to java standard
edition development kit followed by that
accept the license terms download the
jdk file run the jdk file as an
administrator in your local system then
set up the java environment i know this
looks a little bit complex but don't
worry i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a much detailed way how to
install java into your local system
please check that to have a better
understanding of how to install and set
up java in your local system
so followed by this we will learn the
differences between the java standard
edition and java enterprise edition
so the first difference between the
standard edition and the enterprise
edition is the standard edition provides
basic functionalities like defining
classes and objects whereas java
enterprise edition mainly focuses on
high-end and corporate type of java
applications
the second difference between the both
is java standard edition comes with only
the standard specifications which will
be used by a beginner and similarly on
the other hand java enterprise edition
comes with some advanced specifications
which support web applications and
servlets the third difference between
the both is the java standard edition
comes with features like class libraries
and deployment environments whereas the
java enterprise edition has structured
application with the clients business
and enterprise layers
the fourth difference between the both
is
the java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments whereas on the other hand
the java enterprise edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications
the fifth the difference between the
both is the java standard edition is
preferred and used by beginners and on
the other hand the java enterprise
edition is preferred and used by experts
in java field
the sixth difference between the both is
the java standard edition does not have
authentication whereas on the other hand
there are strict rules and regulations
to be followed when using java
enterprise edition related to
authentication
let's get started with what is junit
junit is an open source unit testing
framework for java
here the term unit testing framework
comes into consideration
so before moving forth let's check what
is meant by the term unit testing
unit testing as the name suggests is a
way of testing a unit
here a unit refers to the smallest piece
of code that can be fetched out of the
system
it can be a line of code a method or a
class
keep in mind smaller the chunk of code
the better it is
if the tested units are small the tests
tend to run faster providing a better
insight into the code and its
performance
unit testing helps in the early
identification of defects
it enables the developers to spend more
time on reading the code rather than
writing it
and a successful code helps in boosting
the confidence of the developer
when coming back to junit the framework
is used by java developers to create and
test their codes
it is used for unit testing of the
source code and junit works on the
approach of testing a small part
then coding that and continuing the same
till the end
junit testing helps developers to
develop more reliable readable and a bug
free code
every time a new code is added
all the test cases have to be
re-executed to make sure that nothing is
broken
there are graphs in junit that show the
progress of the test
the graphs show green when the test runs
smoothly and it turns red when the test
fails
now when we know about junit let's see
the way to download and install that
into our system
before you go on to install junit make
sure you have jdk and eclipse
installed in your computer system
so
let's go on
first open your browser in the browser
type
download junit
in downloads a unit we'll get about
junit
in about j unit when we scroll we find
download and install
in download and install
when we go inside that link we will find
two jar files
here let's download these two jar files
when we click on this download button we
will download jar
after the first jar is downloaded let's
go back to that page and download the
second jar file
after both the jar files are downloaded
let's go to the location
here we can see two of our jar files are
downloaded
let's copy these jar files
go to our documents and here in the java
libraries where all the java libraries
are stored let's paste them
after we have pasted these files
we shall open our eclipse
as soon as our eclipse opens
we will first create a project here new
then we shall create a java project
in java project let's name it
junit
installation
click on next
and finish
here
then in this java project
right click on it
and go to the build path option in the
build path option go to configure build
path
here go to the tab libraries
and this side go to add external jars
in add external jars you will get the
location of our two jar files and if you
don't get them you can browse to the
location where you have stored them or
to the location of java libraries
then select these two files
and open them
you will see the two jar files appear
here then click on apply and close
now come back to junit installation that
is a project right click on it
and click on refresh
then right click on the src folder
go to new and create a package
let's name the package to be
junit install
and click on finish
in this package
create a new class
and we shall name the class
junit
install
and click on finish
now let's create a method over here
in the method
we shall type
public void my
junit
install
and system dot
out
dot print ln
welcome
to my
j unit
welcome to my junit
testing
now i will add a library over here
library
test i can see a error now when i hover
over this library
i can see it says import test
so now when i click on it the error is
gone
now we shall run our test
and since we are testing with junit we
shall click here
go on run as junit test
here we shall click on ok
and then we can see in the console it
shows welcome to my junit testing as we
had placed it over here
here on the left side you can see the
junit report
you can see runs one out of one and
there is no or zero errors and same
there are zero failures
so here in space provided you can have
as many number of tests as many bunch of
code you want and with the help of junit
you can test any particular part of the
code
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is
jit so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the runtime
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just in time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question so basically class
loader is the first file to load when
you execute any java program so the java
class loader is the integrated part of
java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java so the answer for this
particular question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes
because java does not follow any
specific rule for the order of
specifiers you place in your program so
when you execute the program with such
pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language
when you declare a local variable or a
global variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if we just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is decode that code in your mind
and provide the output so this would be
the code that we will be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
hundred plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
1 0 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
elearning one zero zero one zero zero as
the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and bank c are
associated with a person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x
but the banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object
cloning i guess the word object learning
is completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason
yes i'll explain you why java is not
completely object oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object-oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object-oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement
pointers in java program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motto was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string pool if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator so after you finish
your program your evaluator might want
to test your code to the extreme levels
so instead of providing a proper number
imagine that your evaluator is providing
a wrong input such as special symbols
sometimes 0 or any other sort of input
so if this kind of input is provided to
your program then your program might
crash so you can avoid this kind of
crash by using exception handling so
basically you can use try and catch
blocks so you can embed your code inside
the try block and say to your program
that if any kind of wrong input such as
special symbol or zero is provided by
the evaluator then send a message saying
wrong input or divide by zero exception
so this kind of approach will provide an
output but this kind of approach will
avoid your program from crashing so this
is how exceptions are handled in real
time so followed by this we have our
next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable will
remain constant throughout the execution
of program so sometimes if you include a
normal variable and provide an operation
on that particular variable then the
value of that particular variable will
change after the execution of program
but when you declare the same variable
using final keyword then no number of
operations or any kind of manipulations
applied onto that variable will not
change the value of that particular
variable so that's a specialty or final
keyword in java so followed by that
we'll dive into the next question that
is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is so
jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers next after the
jdk standard edition we have the java
development kit for enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only and
finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package so basically if
you are trying to access the protected
data member or protected data
manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor written a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows
yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name add so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method then which method to be
overloaded that's the confusion right so
should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass if you are
passing two parameters then the first
method will be executed if you are
passing three parameters then the second
method will be executed so this is how
the method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values of the
variables or data manipulating methods
will not be changed when we have used
the keyword static in front of it so the
question is can we overload a static
method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method
the process worked through an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced so followed by this we have
our next question
so the next question is define
late binding the answer for this
question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the run time
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in
linkedlist than an array
so basically link list and array are the
java collections or in other words it's
also considered as data structure so to
answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is a
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations so consider that your
memory location starts from 100 and your
array has 10 locations so it's a
complete reserved block of from 100 101
102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly bound state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
performed the operation of right
shifting so when you provide a binary
number or binary value then the bits
will be shifted towards the right and
the second symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is
why are generics used in
java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
demon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java the set demon method
is used to create the demon thread in
java programming language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the finalize
method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is
can the keywords this and super
be used together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine
after the jsp page is compiled into a
servlet directives are used to set page
level instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page like
error page and buffer the taglib
directory is used to declare a custom
tag library which is used in the jsp
page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative
discourse of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture so jca
provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question is
explain jpa in java so the answer for
this question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol we shall
quickly begin with the top 10 java
project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online courier management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
anyone which has a good support for java
the most preferable one would be the
eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
mato etc are basically planned and have
reached greater heights today this kind
of project on your resume could make a
huge difference and who knows tomorrow
you might even get into one of those
companies and start working on their
projects or build a company of your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system now
thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate
as their own choice with an unmatchable
ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show
online voting functionality followed by
the abstract we will get into the
technicality of this particular project
so the first phase of this particular
project has the admin phase where the
admin has the right to manage the
candidates manage the voters and their
profiles and passwords and finally
election results followed by the admin
we have the voter or the user of this
particular application the voter or the
user gets to
register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and logout options and next we
have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-health care management
system is a web-based project developed
in java the main aim of this particular
project is to provide effective
management of data related to staff and
patients in hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka and
oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-health care management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
healthcare management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
the system is very reliable and flexible
from all aspects so new features and
modules can be easily integrated into
the system in the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a roller
coaster ride in an amazement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop
the customers can access bank's website
for viewing their account details and
perform the transactions on account as
per the requirement bank employees can
log in and add customer and account
information to perform transactions with
internet banking with internet banking
the break and mode structure of the
traditional bank gets converted into a
click and portal mode thereby giving the
concept of virtual banking a real shape
thus today's banking is no longer
confined to branches e-banking
facilities banking transactions by
customers round the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular project are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account read
raman from the selected account transfer
the amount from one account to another
close the account so the software
requirements for this particular project
are java programming language and and
javascript for scripting language and
oracle for database and tomcat for
server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios
many schools and colleges have now
turned towards the online education
system and are looking forward to
hosting online exams for student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students so the students
can log in update their profile and
password select answers for the mcqs
write answers to questions and finally
closing the session and log out this
particular project can be made a grand
success by making use of simple java
servlets and java programming languages
and server like apache tomcat followed
by the online examinations we have the
smart city smart city java project can
be a web-based software developed to
store the details of a particular city
the main purpose of the project is to
help tourists and other visitors to a
city by providing information about
hotels transportation facilities air
ticket booking shopping details city
news etc the smart city java project
serves the visitors as a guide of the
city and hence the project is called as
city guide project in java using this
project the details of the city can be
accessed from anywhere at any time the
implementation of the city project
promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option
booking that option and payment window
finally the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
design drones that can act like a corp
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or cops or
travel agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have
the bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted
to manage security it stores the old
debug reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the
client-side scripting as the javascript
and the ide for this particular project
would be eclipse with all the my eclipse
plugins and finally the user interface
can be designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java a npr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing algorithms so
followed by vehicle recognition project
we have a last project which is the
speech recognition system so speech
recognizer converts audio to text java x
dot speech dot recognition package
defines the recognizer interface to
build speech recognition plus a set of
supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener comment changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse with
that we have come to an end of this java
crash course for 2022. i hope the
session was informative and interesting
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you need the quotes executed in this
particular tutorial or if you need the
links to all the project ideas discussed
in this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
you